K. GOOD AFTERNOON. WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE HEARING A FEW
REMINDERS MASKS ARE NOT REQUIRED
BUT ARE ENCOURAGE WHILE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND OTHER COMMON
AREAS THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL.
TESTIMONY CAN BE PROVIDED IN
PERSON AND BY PHONE THE NUMBER
FOR PHONE TESTIMONY IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN. THIS NUMBER IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND ALSO APPEARS ON THE
VIDEO FEED. ONCE THE PRIMARY
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WITNESSES
HAVE TESTIFIED I WILL CALL FOR
PHONE TESTIMONY AND TESTIMONY IN
THE HEARING ROOM. WE HAVE
SIXTEEN MEASURES ON THE AGENDA
TODAY PLEASE NOTE THAT ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY CONSENT ITEMS
FOR THIS HEARING. SO WE WANT TO
GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED WITH
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB. TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FIVE OH THREE FOUR OH HOLD
ON I'M SO SORRY DO WE HAVE A
QUORUM OKAY SECRETARY Q. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. JERRY LEWIS HERE
IT IS HERE FLORA. FLOOR HERE
FRIEDMAN GARCIA. GARCIA HERE
MATHIS MCCARTY. MURATSUCHI
MATTEUCCI YOUR SEYARTO STONE
STONE HERE PUT YOUR WOULD HERE.
WHAT WE HAVE A QUORUM READY TO
START MISTER BENNETT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY WOULD REDUCE THE COST
AND PROCESSING TIME FOR NGOS
SEEKING PERMITS FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS OR RESTORATION PROJECTS
BY ALLOWING CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO WAIVER REDUCE COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT FEES. IF A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT DENIES THE
REQUEST TO WAIVE THE FEE
ORGANIZATIONS COULD APPLY
DIRETLY TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WHO CAN UNDER CURRENT
LAW WAIVE THEIR FEES. I WOULD
LIKE TO REALLY EMPHASIZE RIGHT
HERE THEY CAN ONLY DO THIS IF IT
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE LOCAL
COASTAL PLAN THAT WAS APPROVED
BY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. BUT A FEW THOUSAND
DOLLARS MAY NOT SEEM LIKE A
SIGNIFICANT COSTS BUT IT CAN BE
A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO NGOS
OUT THERE TRYING TO DO- GOOD
ENVIRONMENTAL WERE OR PUBLIC
ACCESS WORK- IN ADDITION- AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FURTHERS THE
NATURAL RESOURCE SECRETARIES
CUTTING GREEN TAPE INITIATIVE.
WHICH PROVIDES THAT RESTORATION
AND STEWARDSHIP PROJECTS HAPPEN
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND MORE COST
EFFECTIVELY THAN THEY DO NOW. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY ARE A
LOUISA MORRIS VIA THE PHONE AND
SHAUN DRAKE WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WHO WAS HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE. THANK YOU- OPERATOR Q.
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR OUR-
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. OTHER
WITNESSES LINES ARE OPEN.
AS MISS MORRIS ON THE LINE. BUT
MISSED MORE SIGNATURE NOT ON
MUTE. I APOLOGIZE FOR NEW WITH
FINE ART GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
REVISED IN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LISA MORRIS. AND I'VE
WORKED ON PLANNING PERMITTING
CONSTRUCTING AND MANAGING PUBLIC
ACCESS PROJECT IN THE COASTAL
TOWN FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
THROUGH MY PREVIOUS EMPLOYMENT
WITH THE MEDICINE A LAND TRUST
AND MENDOCINO COUNTY PLANNING
AND BUILDING. THANKS TO THE
COASTAL COMMISSION MENDOCINO
COUNTY HAS THE SECOND HIGHEST
AFTER L. A. COUNTY. DEDICATED
COASTAL PUBLIC ACCESS IN THE
STATE AND I'M PERSONALLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE HISTORY OF ALL
OF THE COASTAL TRAILS IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY. I'M IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY BECAUSE
IT WILL HELP GET MORE PUBLIC
ACCESS PROJECTS OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC THROUGHOUT THE CALIFORNIA
COAST. FASTER AT A LOWER COST
NON PROFITS AND WITH NO DOWNSIDE
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WORKING
FOR AN ORGANIZATION THAT EXISTS
SOLELY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
BENEFITS I ALWAYS THOUGHT IT WAS
STRANGE THAT WE HAVE TO PAY THE
CITY OR THE COUNTY TO PROVIDE A
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE. OF THE
CITY OR THE COUNTY.BUT WHEN I
WORKED AS A COUNTY EMPLOYEE I
REALIZE THAT BECAUSE- ORTEZ IS
PLANNING STAFF NEED TOBE PAID
FOR THEIR TIME THROUGH WHAT'S
CALLED A FULL COST RECOVERY FROM
PERMIT APLICANTS. BUT SADLY
BECAUSE NOT EVERYONE IS FULLY-SUPPORTIVE OF PUBLIC ACCESS IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD LOCALLY
APPROVED PROJECTS CAN GET APPEAL
TO THE COASTAL COMMISSION ANYWAY
CAUSING COSTLY DELAYS TO THESE
PUBLIC BENEFIT PROJECT. AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY WOULD ENABLE
APPLICANTS WHO DON'T GET A PRICE
BREAK AT THE LOCAL LEVELTO
APPLY DIRECTLY TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. WHICH TYPICALLY HAS
LOWER PERMIT FEES THAT MOST
CITIES AND COUNTIES. ASIAN COULD
ALSO WAIVE OR REDUCE PERMIT FEES
. AND ADDITIONAL BENEFITS IS
THAT THIS CAN CUT A YEAR OR MORE
OFF THE PERMITTING TIMELINE AND
THE COMMISSION WOULD STILL
FOLLOW THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LOCAL COASTAL PLAN. FIRST
NONPROFIT SAVE TIME AND MONEY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT STAFFER FREED
UP TO WORK ON OTHER PRIORITY
PROJECTS LOCAL POLICIES ARE
FOLLOWED AND THE PUBLIC GETS THE
BENEFIT OF COASTAL ACCESS SOONER
THAN IT OTHERWISE WOULD. AND THE
SAME CAN BE SAID FOR HABITAT
RESTORATION PROJECTS. SO THAT TO
ME SEEMS LIKE A WIN WIN WIN AND
WIN. THANK YOU FOR. LISTENING TO
MY COMMENTS AND I HOPE YOU'LL
VOTE YES. BY ONE EIGHTY TWENTY
AND SIXTY. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
RIVAS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
SEAN DRAKE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION THE
COMMISSION'S CHAIR AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR HAVE AUTHORIZED TO
SUPPORT POSITION ON THIS BILL.
PROVIDING COASTAL ACCESS AND
RESTORING HABITAT ARE TWO
FUNDAMENTAL GOALS OF THE COASTAL
ACT APPLICANTS FOR SUCH PROJECTS
ARE TYPICALLY NONPROFIT GROUPS
OR PUBLIC AGENCIES. AND THE
FEVER COASTAL DEVELOPMENT PERMIT
IS ANOTHER COST TO IMPLEMENT
THESE PUBLIC BENEFIT PROJECTS.
EVEN A NOMINAL FEE YOU CAN BE A
BARRIER FOR SMALL NONPROFITS
RELY EXTENSIVELY ON FUNDRAISING
AND GRANTS. BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION DOES NOT CHARGE
PERMIT FEES TO PUBLIC AGENCIES
AND ALREADY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
WAIVE OR REDUCE PERMIT FEES TO
NONPROFITS PROPOSING COASTAL
COASTAL ACCESS OR HABITAT
RESTORATION PROJECTS. HOWEVER
THERE IS NO SIMILAR
AUTHORIZATION FOR COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMITS ISSUED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHICH IS THE
MAJORITY PERMITS. WHILE SOME
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO CONSIDER
SUCH REQUESTS IT IS NOT
CONSISTENT ACROSS ALL
JURISDICTIONS. SO THIS BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONSIDER WAIVING
OR REDUCING THE PERMIT FEE FOR A
COASTAL ACCESS OR HABITAT
RESTORATION PROJECT PROPOSED BY
PUBLIC AGENCY OR NONPROFIT. IT
WOULD NOT LIMIT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CURRENT DISCRETION
RATHER IT WOULD EXPLICITLY
AUTHORIZE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
CONSIDER FEE WAIVER REQUESTS FOR
THESE TYPES OF PUBLIC BENEFIT
PROJECTS.SHOULD A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DECLINED A REQUEST
THE BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
APPLICANT TO APPLY DIRECTLY TO
THE COASTAL COMMISSION. IN THESE
CASES THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAM WHICH
CONTAINS ITS LOCALLY ADOPTED
COASTAL LAND USE POLICIES WOULD
REMAIN THE STANDARD OF REVIEW
FOR THE PERMANENT. IN CLOSING.
BECAUSE COASTAL ACCESS AND
HABITAT RESTORATION PROJECTS
PROVIDE PUBLIC BENEFITS THAT ARE
IN LINE WITH STATE PRIORITIES.
IT IS GOOD POLICY FOR THE STATE
TO INCENTIVIZE THEM BY
ENCOURAGING COST SAVINGS WHERE
FEASIBLE. THE BILL WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE GREATER CONTINUITY
BETWEEN HOW THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PROCESS COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMITS FOR PROJECTS
THAT BENEFIT THE PUBLIC. FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN IPHONE. THANK YOU- WE
DON'T HAVE- ANY WITNESSES
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION SO WILL
NOW OPEN IT UP FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION WILL START IN THE
HEARING ROOM. HE SEEN NON
OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
PLEASE GERMAN HE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND AT THIS TIME WE
DEVOTE FOR IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL
START WITH LINE NUMBER FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER FORTY
PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT A MUTE.
WHAT IS MY LINE NUMBER. YOUR
NUMBER FORTY NUMBER FORTY OKAY
YOU MAY USE MY OWN MEAT BUTTER
DO NOT. YES YOU YOU MEAN BUT
WHEN YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING PLEASE.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO ABIGAIL MILE ON BEHALF OF
AN EMPLOYER REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. NEXT TO
THE NUMBER SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PAN HETHERINGTON FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CENTER OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT TWENTY ONE
SIXTY AS WE ARE ONE OF THOSE
NONPROFITS THAT WOULD STRAIGHTEN
THE BENEFIT BY THE FLOOD
DISLOCATION AS WE WORK TO OPEN A
PUBLIC ACCESS TRAILS AND CLOSE
WE THREE DECADES OKAY. STE
REMINDERS- ADDITIONAL WITH JUST
NAME OR- AND PER ON BILL. NEXT
AT NUMBER FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHARLES DAHLE GOTTA REPRESENTING
THE PINNACLE CONSERVATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AT THE TIME
WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE.
THANK YOU I'M ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE. K. C.
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. YEAH K. OF BILL IS
MOVED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY Q.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. JERRY THIS
I FOR THE FLOOR NO FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA GARCIA AYE MATHIS. MATHIS
NO MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MARTUCCI
AYE MATTEUCCI AYE SEYARTO STONE
RIGHT STONE I WOULD. WOOD I.
OKAY THAT BILL HAS SIX BOATS BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ADD ONS
I'M NEXT ITEM TWO ALSO BY
BENNETT- AB. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS NOTED-
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE- COMMITTEE
STAFF WORK ON THIS BILL THE
WINDOW IS CLOSING ON THE TIME WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
SO THERE IS NEW URGENCY TO
ENSURE WE'RE ON TARGET TO MEET
OUR CLIMATE GOALS. WE CAN ONLY
DO THAT IF WE HAVE REGULAR
UPDATES TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
DOING ALL WE CAN TO REDUCE TOXIC
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THIS
BILL IS AIMED AT PROVIDING THIS
CRUCIAL INFORMATION FROM THE
APPROPRIATE STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
A LEGISLATURE PASSED A
GROUNDBREAKING CLIMATE CHANGE
ACT AB THIRTY TWO AS PART OF THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THAT BILL CARB
UNDERTAKES A SCOPING PLAN EVERY
FIVE YEARS TO IDENTIFY HOW THE
STATE CAN REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND MOVE TOWARDS
MEETING OUR CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN CARBERY
LEAST THE LATEST PLAN. HOWEVER
EXCEPT IN A NUMBER OF STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS DEPARTMENTS
AGENCIES DO NOT REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON WHAT
RECOMMENDATIONS THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTING HOW THEY SHOULD
IMPROVE AT. OR IF THEY HAVE
ENCOUNTERED ANY IMPEDIMENTS TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION. WHILE THERE
MAY BE SOME INFORMATION ON THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS ON THEIR
WEBSITE. THE INFORMATION IS
OFTEN NOT DIRECTLY LINKED TO THE
SCOPING PLAN RECOMMENDATIONS.
NOR IS THE FULFILLMENT STATUS.
AS CARP CONCLUDES THE NEXT
COPING PLAN LATER THIS YEAR WE
SHOULD HAVE A MECHANISM IN
PLACE. TO TRACK APPROPRIATELY
THE OUTCOMES AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO WILL REQUIRE PUBLIC
POSTING OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS. POSTINGS
WOULD BE AN AGENCY BE ON THE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
WEBSITES STANDARDIZED IN FORMAT.
AND THEREFORE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE. ANNUAL REPORTING ON
THEIR WEBSITE SHOULD INCREASE
THE FOCUS OF EACH DEPARTMENT AND
AGENCY ON THE SUGGESTED ACTIONS
IDENTIFIED IN THE SCOPING PLAN.
IT ALSO PROVIDES VALUABLE
INFORMATION FOR LEGISLATORS AS
WE ANNUALLY LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE
AND HOW MUCH PROGRESS WE'RE
MAKING AND WHAT ARE THE
IMPEDIMENTS TO MOVING FORWARD. I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND I
HAVE- NICOLE KURIAN FROM
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
DANIEL GROUP GUSEN CAMP OF
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
BIODIVERSITY HERE WITH ME TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU I'M FIRST WITNESS. THANK YOU
TURN MEMBERS THE STATE'S
LANDMARK CLIMATE LAW AB THIRTY
TWO IS OFTEN ASSOCIATED WITH
REGULATIONS ADOPTED DIRECTLY BY
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD SUCH AS
THE CAP AND TRADE SYSTEM AND THE
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD HOWEVER
SINCE ITS PASSAGE AB THIRTY TWO
HAS ALSO RELIED ON OTHER
AGENCIES TO TARGET REDUCTIONS
GOING BEYOND LOOKING AT
TAILPIPES AND SMOKESTACKS TO
FIND OPPORTUNITIES TO TACKLE GHG
EMISSIONS ACROSS. OTHER SECTORS
. FOR EXAMPLE WASTE REDUCTION
RECYCLING AND COMPOSTING UNDER
CAL RECYCLE HAVE BEEN CENTRAL TO
THE STATE'S CLIMATE STRATEGY
BECAUSE THEY ARE AMONG THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE WAYS. TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS. AMONG OTHER RELEVANT
STRATEGIES AT THE SCOPING PLAN
CHARGE CAL RECYCLE WITH
AGGRESSIVE EFFORTS TO INCREASE
COMMERCIAL RECYCLING DECREASE TO
DISPOSE OF ORGANIC WASTE AND TO
REDUCE LANDFILL EMISSIONS. CDFA
WAS SIMILARLY TASKED WITH
SUPPORTING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HEALTHY SOILS AND CARBON
SEQUESTRATION ON NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS. DESPITE THE
ORIGINAL FOCUS ON CROSS AGENCY
COOPERATION IS BEEN DIFFICULT TO
QUANTIFY THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE STRATEGIES IN SUBSEQUENT
YEARS. MOST AGENCIES DON'T
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
WHAT RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
IMPLEMENTING HOW THEY SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED OR IF THEY HAVE
ENCOUNTERED ANY IMPEDIMENTS TO
IMPLEMENTATION AND WHEN THEY DO
THIS INFORMATION AND THE STATUS
OF THIS IMPLEMENTATION ISN'T
USUALLY DIRECTLY LINKED TO THEIR
SCOPING PLAN. RECOMMENDATIONS
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE ISSUE BY
CREATING A SYSTEM OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALL STATE
AGENCIES CHARGED WITH
IMPLEMENTING PARTS OF THE
SCOPING PLAN WHICH WILL BE
CRITICAL TO MAKING SURE WE
ACTUALLY MEET OUR TARGETS. AND
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES TO
RECTIFY ANY DEFICIENCIES. THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
SO WE'RE READY FOR OUR NEXT
WITNESS THAT I BELIEVE IS ON THE
PHONE. LINES OPERATOR. YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
OUR WITNESS FOR AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO. HELLO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT AND CO AUTHORS FOR THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. MY NAME
IS DANIEL POLICING CAMPAIGN
DETECTED OF DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY C. ID IS A STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT THAT FOR THREE DECADES
HAS LISTENED TO SCIENTISTS AND
TRANSLATED SCIENCE SO THAT WE
CAN UNDERSTAND AND SAVE THIS
GLOBAL BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOT THAT
WE CALL HOME. AS YOU WELL KNOW
CLIMATE CHANGE POSES AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT FOR HUMAN
COMMUNITIES AND FOR THE BIO
DIVERSITY THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA
SO SPECIAL. WE'RE ALREADY SEEING
UNACCEPTABLE IMPACT ELEVATED
HEAT IS KILLING CALIFORNIANS IN
DECEMBER AND A DEVASTATING
NATURAL COMMUNITIES INCIDENTS
LIKE SLAPPED SUMMER'S HEATWAVE
IN THE PACIFIC NORTHWEST THEY
KILLED A BILLION TIDE POOL.
ANIMALS ARE BECOMING
INCREASINGLY COMMON. THIS
PLANNING AN MP TOLD TAKING A
CLIMATE. AND AB FIVE TWO AND
THAT'S APPROACH FROM THAT PLAN.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE WERE THAT
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOW BEEN DONE
BEFORE WE DON'T REALLY KNOW HOW
TO FULLY TODAY EVERY SECTOR OF
OUR SOCIETY. IN A TERRIBLY SHORT
TIME LINE. TO SCIENTISTS THIS
WHOLE PROCESS IS A FANTASTICALLY
COMPLICATED MULTI TRILLION
DOLLAR EXPERIMENT IT'S A NESTED
SET OF HYPOTHESES FOR HOW THE
WORLD WORKS AND THEN FOR ACTIONS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE TO
TEST. HOW CARBON BUDGETS WILL
RESPOND. NO SENATORS WHATEVER
SET UP EVEN A SIMPLE EXPERIMENT
WITHOUT FIRST DOCUMENTING
ACTIONS WILL TAKE AND THE
OUTCOMES TO BE MEASURED. THAT'S
WHAT AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO
DOES IT REQUIRES PARTICIPANTS TO
MAKE A LIST OF WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO. AND THEN CHECK IN
ON IT. TO SEE WHETHER THEY DID
IT. THIS WILL IMPROVE OUR F. TO
SERVE CLIMATE CHANGE AND ONLY.
IMPROVED OVER BY THE- ALSO
HOPING THAT IT COULD EVEN
IMPROVE CAPACITY FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY MORE BROADLY
ACROSS GOVERNMENT. IF AGENCIES
ARE SUPPORTED IN DEVELOPING SEMI
AUTOMATED SYSTEM FOR TRACKING
RESPONSIBILITIES AND OUTCOMES.
OTHER THAN JUST DEPENDING ON
UNDERPAID STATE SCIENTISTS TO
KIND OF CARRY IT ALL ON THEIR
OVERLOADED TO DO LISTS. THE
INSTITUTE FOR BIODIVERSITY
SUPPORTS AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
TWO. BECAUSE IT BRINGS MUCH
NEEDED TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT EFFORTS UNDER WAY
TODAY. THANK YOU JERRY INVESTING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR MOVING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT WERE READY
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. WE'LL
START WITH THE HEARING ROOM. C.
NINE OPERATOR HUGH PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO. EMILY AND JOHN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. SECOND ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THE
MANAGER AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE IN OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WHO WILL OKAY
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND- FOR THIS BILL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES AND I
JUST WOULD AGAIN LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFFERS BUT QUITE
A BIT OF WORK WENT INTO THIS
SAID AND MY STAFF AND IT
PERFECTLY AND WORKING WITH-
CARPETS ARE WORKING ON THE PLAN
AND SO WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING WE
CAN AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THIS BILL. IS AS PRACTICAL IN
THIS IMPLEMENTATION AS POSSIBLE-
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER BENNETT. OF THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. JERRY THIS HI RIVAS I
FLOOR FLOOR I FRIEDMAN GARCIA.
GARCIA I MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE MURATSUCHI AYE
SEYARTO STONE STONE I WOULD.
WOOD I. THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES
IT'S OUT AND LEAVE IT. I WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. K. NEXT ITEM THREE AB.
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
SORRY ARE WE DOING TWENTY FIVE
NINETY THREE OR. TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN RIGHT TO. THE ITEM THREE.
THE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN WOULD DIRECT THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION TO COMPLETE A
COMPLETE. AND CONDUCT A
COMPREHENSIVE COST ANALYSIS OF A
VOLUNTARY STATE OFFSHORE OIL AND
GAS LEASE BUYOUT STRATEGY.
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS OFFSHORE OIL
AND GAS OPERATORS TO PRODUCE OIL
AND GAS PURSUANT TO THE STATE
LEAST INDEFINITELY AS LONG AS
IT'S ECONOMICALLY REASONABLE FOR
THEM TO DO SO. THE DECISION TO
DECOMMISSION OR CONTINUE
OPERATION RESIDES WITH THE OIL
AND GAS OPERATOR UNLESS
OPERATORS DISCONTINUE PRODUCTION
ON THEIR OWN OR DEFAULT ON THEIR
LEASE THE STATE WE NEED TO. BUY
OUT THE OPERATOR'S INTEREST IN
THESE LEASES IN ORDER TO
DISCONTINUE OPERATIONS AND BEGIN
THE DECOMMISSIONING PROCESS AND
TO AVOID SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
LEGAL COSTS AND UNCERTAINTIES.
CALIFORNIA'S ROLE AS A GLOBAL
LEADER IN CLIMATE PROTECTION AND
CHAMPION OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
NECESSITATES THE NEED TO END
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
FOR THE TRANSITION IN THE STATE
TOWARDS A 100% RENEWABLE ENERGY.
THIS TRANSITION MUST BE
CALCULATED AND THOUGHTFUL USING
DATA TO GUIDE THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS. AB TWENTY FIFTY
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE THE
COMMISSION TO ANALYZE THE REPORT
ON THE ESTIMATED FINANCIAL
IMPACT IF THE STATE INITIATED A
VOLUNTARY BUYOUT OF THE
REMAINING ELEVEN OFFSHORE OIL
AND GAS LEASES IN STATE WATERS.
THIS COST IT WILL PROVIDE THE
DATA NECESSARY TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS AND ENACT PRACTICAL
SOLUTIONS TO AN OFFSHORE OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I JUST WANT TO KNOW AND LAST
WEEK ACTUALLY AND OIL AND GAS
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
IN CALIFORNIA ON STATE LANDS
WHEN WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO SEE
THE OIL SPILLS THAT AFFECTED
ORANGE COUNTY AND MY DISTRICT
THIS LAST FALL. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOTH VOTE AND STAY WITH ME I
HAVE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. CRISTINA CONDON
KUNKEL DEPUTY COMPTROLLER FOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY IN THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND SHERI
PEMBERTON CHIEF EXEC EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS LEGISLATIVE. LIAISON AT
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
CONGAL DEPUTY COMPTROLLER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TODAY ON AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN. AN IMPORTANT
BILL THE CONTROLLER IS PLEASED
TO SPONSOR. AS CALIFORNIA'S
CHIEF FISCAL OFFICER AND CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION. CONTROLLER HE
UNDERSTANDS THE NEED FOR A
CAREFUL COMPREHENSIVE AND
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE APPROACH TO
ENDING OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS. ENDING OFFER GAL
GADOT LIVE OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION. FACES CHALLENGES
THAT ARE DEEPLY ROOTED IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORICAL
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK. EXISTING
LAW AND THE LEASES THEMSELVES
CONTAIN LANGUAGE THAT
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS OPERATORS TO
OPERATE INDEFINITELY. THE FIRST
OFFSHORE OIL WELL WAS DRILLED IN
EIGHTEEN NINETY EIGHT WE HAVE
BEEN EXTRACTING OIL AND GAS OFF
SHORE FOR MORE THAN A CENTURY.
WE CANNOT SIMPLY PULL THE PLUG
OVERNIGHT WITHOUT COMMITTING THE
STATE TO SIGNIFICANT LEGAL COSTS
AND UNCERTAINTIES. AN
INVOLUNTARY TOP TERMINATION
WOULD ALMOST CERTAINLY EXTENDS
THE LIFETIME OF THESE LEASES
WELL OPERATORS DEFENDS THEIR
BINDING CONTRACTS IN COURT. AND
WHILE LEGAL COSTS TO TAXPAYERS
ACCUMULATE. THIS IS WHY WE NEED
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN. WHICH
WILL PROVIDE THE STATE WITH
CONCRETE AND CRITICAL DATA TO
EVALUATE AND NEGOTIATE A
VOLUNTARY BUYOUT STRATEGY. THE
COMPLETE FISCAL IMPACT OF ENDING
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS IS
CURRENTLY UNKNOWN. IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE AND IRRESPONSIBLE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT FULLY
UNDERSTANDING THE COSTS THIS
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS WILL
DELIVER THE INFORMATION
NECESSARY FOR POLICY MAKERS TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS AND ACT
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS. AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN IS A CRUCIAL
INVESTMENT TOWARD OUR RENEWABLE
ENERGY TRANSACTION. THE
CONTROLLER RESPECTFULLY URGES
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL WITH AN
AYE VOTE TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS AND GUIDE THE STATE ON
THE PATHWAY TO A FOSSIL FREE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SHERI PEMBERTON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LANDS COMMISSION THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL IS TO GATHER THE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION NECESSARY.
FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO PROCEED
WITH ENDING OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE OF THE STATUTORY
FRAMEWORK AND THE TERMS OF THE
EXISTING LEASES WHICH ARE
CONTRACTS THE STATE'S OFFSHORE
OIL AND GAS LESSEES HAVE THE
LEGAL RIGHT AN OBLIGATION TO
CONTINUE PRODUCING OIL AND GAS.
AS LONG AS IT IS ECONOMIC FOR
THEM TO DO SO. THE COMMISSION IS
AWARE OF THE RATIONALITY OF THE
SITUATION GIVEN THE CLIMATE
CRISIS BUT THAT IS THE LAW. AND
WHILE CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
POLICIES OF THE NINETEEN FIFTIES
AND SIXTIES ARE NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR POLICIES
AND VALUES TODAY. THE STATE IS
BOUND BY THE TERMS OF THE
CONTRACTS ENTERED INTO DECADES
AGO. NO UNILATERAL OFFSHORE OIL
AND GAS LEASE TERMINATION AS
POSSIBLE WITHOUT IT AGO SHE DID
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE COMMISSION
AND THE LASSIES. THIS BILL WILL
YIELD THE INFORMATION NECESSARY
TO NEGOTIATE SUCCESSFUL
AGREEMENTS THAT WOULD AND
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS
WITHOUT INCURRING. MASSIVE LEGAL
AND FINANCIAL COST DELAYS AND
UNCERTAINTIES. THE COMMISSION AS
THE RIGHT ENTITY TO MANAGE THIS
STUDY. IT'S EXPERIENCED WITH
SECURING THE SERVICES OF
RESERVOIR ENGINEERS AND
ASSESSING COMPLEX OIL AND GAS
RESERVOIR INTERNET INFORMATION.
THE STUDY WOULD INVOLVE
ARRANGING FOR A RESERVOIR
ENGINEER TO DETERMINE WHAT
RESERVES REMAIN AND ARE LIKELY
TO BE PRODUCED. IT WILL ALSO
INVOLVE ECONOMIST AN APPRAISAL
ANALYSIS TO ASSESS THE PRICE OF
OIL PRODUCTION PRODUCTION
TRAJECTORY. AND THE COST
OPERATORS BEAR TO PRODUCE OIL
AND GAS WE WOULD USE THAT
INFORMATION TO DERIVE A VALUE
THAT WOULD BE THE FOUNDATION FOR
NEGOTIATION TO SUCCESSFULLY AND
OILAND GAS OPERATIONS. THIS IS
A SMART THOUGHTFUL AND LEGALLY
SOUND BILL THAT BEST POSITIONS
CALIFORNIA TO. AND OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS AND OFFSHORE STATE
WATERS AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AT THE- THANK YOU. WE
HAVE ONE WITNESS IN OPPOSITION-
MISTER SHAWN. WAS AT ONE TIME.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION. MUCH
BETTER THAN THE PHONES. PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
ON ONE TIME FOR THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO
THE COST STUDY WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT IN THE VALUE
OF IT WE WOULD HOWEVER
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS THAT THE
AUTHOR CONSIDER CLARIFYING
AMENDMENT- THAT THE STUDY BE
COMPLETED BY AN ENTITY WITH
EXPERTISE IN DETERMINING THE
VALUE OF SOMETHING AS COMPLEX AS
OFFSHORE OIL LEASES SO THANK YOU
IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT WERE READY FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FIRST IN THE HEARING
ROOM. C. NINE OPERATOR KEY
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
TWO FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. SECOND ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. I'M SURE
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN Q. THANK YOU THAT. OKAY WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND I'M
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YOU SEE NINE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES- WE
WILL CONSIDER OF THE OPPOSITION-
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
CONSIDERATION MY UNDERSTANDING
FROM STATE LANDS AS THIS IS
SOMETHING THEY WOULD USE AN
EXTERNAL CONSULTANT FOR ANYWAYS
SO I'M NOT SURE WE NEED TO HAVE
IN THE LANGUAGE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY WITHIN
THEIR- DEPARTMENT TO DO IT SO
I'M- YOU KNOW I'M NOT SURE WE
NEED AN ACTUAL MOMENT BUT WILL
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
HAVE A- THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
JERRY THIS. I REQUEST HIGH FLOOR
OF THE- NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA GARCIA AYE MATHIS. MATHIS
NO MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE MATTEUCCI AYE
SEYARTO STONE STONE I WOULD. I
WOULD HI. OKAY THE BILL HAS SIX
BOATS I WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON-
NEXT IS ITEM FOR AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY THREE ALSO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ANOTHER TV H.
SPECIAL THIS IS A BILL I WROTE
MYSELF- SO YOU KNOW I AM IF YOU
HAVE ANY FEEDBACK OR THOUGHTS
I'M HAPPY TO INCLUDE THEM. FIRST
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT ALL THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS OF THE BILL I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF-
AND THEIR INPUT AND ADVICE ON
THIS ISSUE AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
THREE WOULD REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION TO
REQUIRE BECAUSE THE DEVELOPMENT
PERMIT APPLICANTS WHERE FEASIBLE
TO INCLUDE IN THEIR PLANNING AND
DESIGN OF A PUBLIC PROJECT HOW
THEY PLAN TO BUILD OR CONTRIBUTE
TO PROMOTING BLUE CARBON
PROJECTS THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
WHICH IS THE BILL AS FOLLOWS.
DEFINED BLUE. TITLE OR MARINE
HABITATS OR ECOSYSTEMS INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO KELP FORESTS
SEAGRASSES AND WETLANDS THAT
CAPTURE CARBON NO THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL TO ALL PUBLIC PROJECTS
THAT IMPACT AREAS OF THE
COASTLINE WITH THE NEXUS TO BLUE
CARBON NOT JUST PUBLIC PROJECTS
IN GENERAL TO EXPAND POTENTIAL
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE CARBON
REQUIRE THE COMMISSION TO
REQUIRE APPLICANTS TO MITIGATE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THE A
BLUE CARBON PROJECTS STRIKE THE
PROVISION REQUIRING APPLICANTS
TO CALCULATE THE CARBON CAPTURE
OF BLUE CARBON SAYS THAT WOULD
BE APPLYING FOR DIFFERENT
PROJECTS. THIS BILL IS THE
RESULT OF A TRANSPORTATION
PROJECT THAT WE HAD IN NORTH
COUNTY SAN DIEGO WE'RE WIDENING
OF THE I. FIVE FREEWAY LANES ARE
JUST A NUMBER OF ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY RESIDENTS
IN REGARD TO THE IMPACT OF
WILDLIFE LIVING IN THE SIX
COASTAL LAGOONS THIRTY TWO ACRES
OF WETLANDS AND SEVENTY FOUR
ACRES OF COASTAL SAGE IT'S BEEN
AN EX EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESSFUL
PROJECT I THINK WE MAY BE DOING
IT UP AND DOWN THE COAST. AND
DURING THE COURSE THE PERMITTING
PROCESS THE COASTAL COMMISSION
APPROVED THE PROJECT WITH
IMPROVEMENTS RELATED TO
ENHANCING MARINE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
HABITATS THIS INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO MITIGATING IMPACTS
TO NATURAL RESOURCES CAN BE
REPLICATED TO BUILD OR RESTORE
BLUE CARBON SINKS BLUE CARBON
ISN'T THE MOST EFFECTIVE YET
OVERLOOKED METHOD FOR LONG THE
QUESTION AND STORAGE OF CARBON
BLUE CARBON ECOSYSTEMS NOT ONLY
PREVENT CLIMATE CHANGE THEY ALSO
PROTECT COASTAL COMMUNITIES FROM
THE HARMFUL IMPACTS SUCH AS
RISING SEAS AND FLOODING AND
PROVIDE IMPORTANT HABITATS FOR
MARINE LIFE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU. OF
DON'T HAVE ANY WAY. REGISTERED
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN IT UP- TWO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WE'LL START WITH THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE- OPERATOR
Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. OF AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE. AND
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. YEAH TWENTY FIVE
AND ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT FOR.
AGAIN WHAT ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
TWO IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL START
WITH NUMBER SIXTY FOUR. ONE SIX
FOUR PLEASE YET. WILL MOVE TO
LINE NUMBER SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER SIX IS MAKE SURE NOT ON
MUTE. FONG FELL BY POLICIES. AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
OUR QUEUE HE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. K. C. NINE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US ANOTHER TBH SPECIAL.
PERMITS FOR BETTER
BOERNER HORVATH SORRY- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. I THINK
WE NEED A MOTION. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHERRY FOR US HI.
RIVAS AYE FLORA. FLOOR NO
FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS NO MCCARTY- TO
CHANGE MURATSUCHI I SEE STONE
STONE I WOULD. WOOD I. THE BILL
HAS FIVE BOTH LEAVE IT OPEN.
NEXT PETRIE-NORRIS ITEM- THAT WE
GET THAT BOB. OKAY OKAY WE'LL GO
AND TAKE AYE TWELVE SINCE SHE'S
THE ONLY AUTHOR IN THE ROOM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR HI. AND
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU I
HEARING A MOTION AND A SECOND
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF WITH MY
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS AND WE HAVE
ONE WITNESS WHO WILL I HAD A BIT
OF AN OVERVIEW I'M SO I AM HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWO SEVEN THREE
FOUR I WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT
OUR COASTAL COMMUNITIES HAVE.
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO PREPARE
FOR THE IMPACTS OF SEA LEVEL
RISE AND PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR A COASTAL HAZARD EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM- THIS BUILDS ON
AB SIXTY SIX WHICH IS ACTUALLY
AUTHORED BY OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
IN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THAT
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND WITH
THAT I'LL GO AHEAD AND WELCOME
MY EYE WITNESS DR MARK
MERRYFIELD FROM THE SCRIPPS
INSTITUTION OF OCEANOGRAPHY IS
JOINING US ON THE PHONE. I HAVE.
THANK YOU OPERATOR WERE LOOKING
FOR DOCTOR MARK MERRYFIELD- I
DON'T BELIEVE THIS IS FOR ITEM
TWELVE AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
FOUR. AND I MISS MIRFIELD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU TERRY THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
SPECIAL THANKS TO ASSEMBLY ONE
NOURSE INTRODUCING THE SPELL OF
THE RESEARCH OUTLINING ET TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR WITH PROVEN
SPENDING MARCH COUNTY COASTAL
EROSION PROCESSES QUICK
LANDSLIDE COASTAL FLOODING. THE
THREE IS CRITICAL TO THAT
CLIMATE AT THE PLANNING TO COME
STRATEGY FOR THIS. AND WILL
PROVIDE A TEMPLATE PERSIST
POLITICAL COSTA COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW FROM
YOU CAN KEEP. OF CLICK CLICK THE
COLLAPSE AND REGIMENTATION
CRITICAL ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT THIS REGION IS ALREADY
GRAPPLING WITH EXTREME EVENTS
THAT WILL WORSEN CONSIDERABLY
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE WHAT. THE
STUDY OUT ONE OF THE BILL WOULD
INVOLVE COMPREHEND CLOSELY
MONITORING EFFORT COLLABORATION
IS HEREBY. TO PROVIDE THE STATE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ESTABLISHING
ADVANCED COASTAL CLIFFS
LANDSLIDE RUSSIAN FLOOD EARLY
WARNING SYSTEMS. THE RESEARCH
TEAM WILL CONDUCT SITE SPECIFIC
REAL TIME CLICK MONITORING USING
HIGH RESOLUTION ADVANCED
TECHNICAL CENTER TECHNOLOGY
DEVELOPED AT SCRIPTS. IN
ADDITION WE WILL DEPLOY A NOVEL
TECHNIQUE THAT MEASURES COASTAL
SEDIMENT CHANGE THE BETTER.
STAFF CLICK THAT. YOUR TIME.
FLOOD MODEL WILL BE DEVELOPED
THESE WATER. BILLS OPTIONAL
MAPLE THAT BUT I WANT STATE.
ABOUT WE WOULD INSTALL A
GEODETIC CENTER NOW ON THE
COASTLINE CHIMPS FOR CAN A CO
FLOODING LANDSLIDE. WE BELIEVE
THE RESULTS FROM THIS CALL IN
HER PAST BUT BASS. AFTER WHILST
THE STATE RESULT TO CLAIM CHANGE
IMPACT. IN SCIENCE NOT THAT
ADAPTATION FOR OTHER PLEASE.
THANK YOU TO RIVAS FOR ALL
SPEAKING AT THE YOU AGAIN
ASSEMBLY BY FUTURE CLEARLY SHOW
ON THIS. THANK YOU- WE DON'T A
WITNESS REGISTER IN OFFICE. SO
WE'LL GO AND MOVE TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION STARTING IN THE
HEARING ROOM. K. C. NINE
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FOUR. IN
FIRST SUPPORTER OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. IN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE WE'LL GO
TO NUMBER SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
LINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALLAFRICA MILE AND A HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHER CENTER Q.
THANK YOU AND ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MISTER MURATSUCHI YES
I AM. NOTED FROM THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT- THAT ONE OF THE
OTHER- AREAS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS AT HIGHEST
RISK FOR RUSSIAN IS IN MY
DISTRICT AND PALACE VERDES AND
I. I KNOW THAT THERE ARE SIMILAR
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF. EROSION
AND THE IMPACT ON THE- ON-
BECAUSE SOME OF OUR LOCAL ROADS-
HAVING TO BE REPAIRED EVERY YEAR
BECAUSE OF THE CONSTANT-
LANDSLIDE AND EROSION- PROCESS-
I WAS CURIOUS HOW YOU CAME ABOUT
. IDENTIFYING THE SCRIPTS
INSTITUTE- IS SPECIFICALLY TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH ON THIS. SCRIPT
AS SAM AS I IMAGINE YOU KNOW IS
KIND OF WORLD RENOWNED- IN IN
TERMS OF THEIR EXPERTISE AND
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
ON AT THE INITIATIVE IN SENIOR
COUNTY ASSERT THAT FELT LIKE A
NATURAL FIT AN EXTENSION. ON BUT
CERTAINLY IF THEY'RE TO THE
POINT THAT YOU'RE MAKING- THE
CHALLENGES THAT TO OUR COASTAL
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING ARE BEING
FELT UP AND DOWN THE STATE. OKAY
MABIALA AFTER INTRODUCED A BILL
LEFT FOR THEM TO STUDY TELLS FOR
HIS NEXT YEAR WE SHOULD YEAH WE
COULD WE SHOULD CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION AND WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ARE ANY I NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND SOME OF. A GOOD WAY TO
HAVE IT OKAY SORRY I THINK WARY-
WE DEBT SORRY WE HAVE ALREADY
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE OF A SIMPLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I'M SECRETARY THE
WAIT THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL JERRY THIS AYE REVERSE AYE
FLOOR. LARA AYE FRIEDMAN. GARCIA
HI CHRISTY I MATHIS- MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY. MURATSUCHI IT'S A G. I.
C. R. TWO STONE. STONE I WOULD
WOOD HI. OKAY WE HAVE SEVEN
VOTES- WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
PEOPLE TO ADD ON THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
WATCHING A MOVIE BILL. THANK YOU
THIS IS A HARDY IS HERE WILL
START WITH YEAH ITEM SIXTEEN AB
TWENTY TWO OH SEVEN SO GREAT
PROPOSAL A GREAT LAW HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND I HAVE MY
NOTES OVER THERE BUT- AS WELL
TAKE THE HECK OF. THE STATE. THE
WAY ON THANK YOU I REALLY DON'T
NEED A LOT OF NOTES ON THIS THIS
IS OUR ONE OF OUR BEST PROGRAMS
WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA EVERYONE
LOVES THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS THIS IS
SENSUALLY MODERNIZES THE ACT TO
MAKE IT A MORE VIABLE FOR THE
COURT TO SERVE- ITS MISSION AND
ALSO SERVE YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE
SLOGAN THAT IT'S- AND MISERABLE
CONDITIONS LOW WAGES BUT-
TREMENDOUS WORK- CERTAINLY WE
HELP HELP WORK IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SPACES WORK WHICH
IS LIKE HOW FAR CALTRANS STATE
PARKS. WE ALSO HAVE TREMENDOUS-
ROLE HERE IN HELPING CHANGE THE
LIVES OF YOUNG PEOPLE A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO- YOU KNOW DIDN'T
HAVE THE BEST ACADEMIC SKILLS
ARE HAD TROUBLE WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM GO
THROUGH THE COURT AND TURN A
LIFE AROUND SO THIS THING THIS
MEASURE WOULD DO TWO THINGS IT
WOULD MODERNIZE THE COURTSTO
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A DIRECT
CONTRACTING AND LEASING
AUTHORITY TO ALLOW THEM TO
STREAMLINE. THEIR PROGRAMMING AS
WELL AS IT WILL PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
GO THROUGH THE COURT TO HAVE A
LEG UP WHEN IT COMES TO GETTING
THE STATE JOB WITHOUT ASKING
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER- YOU HAVE ONE WITNESS
RIGHT. OR IF YOU SAY SO. OKAY WE
HAVE ONE THAT'S REGISTERED TO
TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE- MISTER
KERRY WENT. OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES OF
THEIR SHIPS- IT AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS KERRY
WENT I'M HERE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO OH
SEVEN. NOT HERE THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE TCP BUT AS
A FORMER CHOIR MEMBER AND
PRIVATE EVENTS. I TALKED OF THE
JUNIOR COLLEGE WHEN I WAS
NINETEEN TO DURING THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
WHERE IT BECAME A CHEERLEADER.
WILDLAND FIREFIGHTER AND
COMPLETED ABOUT COULD YOU TO
HELP THE FACT THAT THE WORK THAN
A PAYCHECK WITH EDUCATION LIFE
EXPERIENCE THAT I DROPPED FROM.
TO IN ADDITION TO LEARNING
BUILDING RESPONSIBILITIES ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I MIGHT REMEMBER
MY TIME IN THE CAR BURKE. BUT
THE RACIAL CULTURAL. OF ME.
WORKING ALONG. AND BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
AND BACKGROUNDS. CREDIBLY
ENRICHING. FOR ME. BUT A QUICK
RETURN. I UNDERSTAND THE VALUE
OF KNOWING AND UNDERSTANDING
PEOPLE FOR WHO THEY REALLY ARE.
NOT JUDGING OTHER PEOPLE BASED
ON RACE THAT WOULD BE SEXUAL.
ORIENTATION THE LIFE EXPERIENCE
. MAKING FRIENDS AND CASES BY
WILDLIFE. RISKING MY LIFE WITH
FELLOW CORPS MEMBERS. BILL TRUST
AND UNDERSTANDING UNLIKE. ANY
OTHER EXPERIENCE I HAD AT.
THIRTY YEARS OF ALWAYS BEEN
ATTRACTIVE OPTION FOR YOU
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES BUT
EXPLICITLY STATING THE INTENTION
TO PRIORITIZE UNDERSERVED YOUTH
PUBLICLY SOLIDIFIED. COMMITMENT
TO UPLIFTING YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE SO OFTEN UNDER SUPPORTED AND
STRUGGLING TO FIND A PATH
THROUGH THE COMPLICATED
TRANSITION INTO ADULTHOOD. I
SUPPORT AB TWENTY TWO OH SEVEN
BEATING AT THAT THE COR WOULD
CONDUCT OUTREACH TO
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY I SUPPORT AND
BINDING CONTRACT OF APARTMENT
JUSTICE. IN CULTURAL COMPETENCY
AND EDUCATION TO BETTER DEVELOP
AND SUPPORT A DIVERSE COUNTRY OF
NATURAL. RESOURCE CONSERVATION
PRACTITIONERS. I WANT TO TAX. I
WORK FOR CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
US FOREST SERVICE THE NATIONAL
SERVICE AS TRUCK LEADER I THINK
BACK TO FULL LEADERS WHEN I WAS
OF THEM OF THAT. THE EDUCATION
GET FROM MY WITH THE KEYS ABOUT
ME TO WORK FOR AN EXTRA IN AND
FEDERAL AGENTS. BEFORE
COMPLETING MY FORMAL EDUCATION
THE GOAL OF AB TWENTY TWO SEVEN
YOUR COVERAGE OF FRED FORMER
CORPS MEMBERS STICKING POINT IS
NOT TO CORPS MEMBERS IN
BENEFICIAL FOR STATE AGENCIES
LOOKING FOR COMMITTED BECAUSE.
CANDIDATES REMEMBER THAT MORE.
AND I'M MENTALLY PHYSICALLY TO
BE JOB MOST PEOPLE AND DESERVE
THE ACTRESS OF AFTER. IN OUR
LIVES THE STATE CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
WITNESSED REGISTERED AND- SO
WE'RE GOING AND HEAR FROM
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES STARTING IN
THE HEARING ROOM. SEE NINE
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR SOME ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY TWO ZERO SEVEN. WHAT. IN
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AT
THE TIME WE DO HAVE TO IN OUR
QUEUE WELL FIRST CO TWO NUMBER
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THANK YOU. I NAME IS J. COLEMAN
I'M A PUBLIC SCHOOL MIDDLE
SCHOOL TEACHER I'VE BEEN A
TEACHER THERE FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THE SAME SCHOOL. I'M
CALLING IN TO SUPPORT THE POCKET
FARCE BILL I HOPE THIS IS THE
RIGHT TIME. BECAUSE THEY JUST
DIED IN THE QUEUE- I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT MY HEALTH BUT SAYING THAT
WE'RE DOING AB TWENTY CORRECT
ZERO SEVEN RIGHT NOW. WE'RE ONLY
TAKING ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF ITEM
SIXTEEN. AB TWENTY TWO ZERO
SEVEN. WELL MEXICO DO NUMBER SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO EVERYONE
BILE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO ZERO
SEVEN THANK YOU. QUANEX CO TO
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE. HER SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL
MOVE TO NUMBER EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THERE MY NAME'S
ALICIA GRAVES AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE POCKET FIRST BILL
OF THE CALIFORNIA. PERRANCE.
CHIU STUDENT. TAKE OUT A- OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF ITEM SIXTEEN RIGHT
NOW. AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN OUR QUEUE. THANK
YOU. ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
K. C. NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AT THE- THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. I THINK I BELIEVE
WHERE SU CHI'S SECONDED. MATHIS
BY MISTER MATHIS SELTZER THANK
YOU. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS THE PATH TO
APPROPRIATIONS JERRY BUSS HI
RIVAS I FLORA FLORA I FRIEDMAN
GARCIA GARCIA AYE MATHIS. MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I SAY ARE
TO STONE STONE I WOULD. WOOD HI
. OKAY WE HAVE EIGHT VOTES BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. NOW WILL GO BACK IN
FILE ITEM ORDER TO ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS A HOT COMMITTEE
WORLD. THE I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN
A BILL THAT'S GOING TO HELP
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION- IN
REBUILDING AN EQUITABLE FUTURE
WHEN PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN SIGNED
THE HISTORIC INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE HE CALLED 440% OF THOSE
RESOURCES TO GO TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUT LESS STATES
ALONE TO BUILD UP WITH THAT
FRAMEWORK CAN AND SHOULD LOOK
LIKE FOR CALIFORNIA TO MEET THIS
GOAL WE ARE PROPOSING IN THIS
BILL THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
JUSTICE. FORTY COMMISSION.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT BLACK BROWN
POOR INDIGENOUS WORLD IN. MANY
OTHER COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN LEFT
OUT WHEN IT COMES TO BUILDING
SUSTAINABLE INFRASTRUCTURE
ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER. THIS BILL
IS ABOUT USING THOSE RESOURCES
AND REPAIRING SOME THAT HARM
IT'S ALSO ABOUT CREATING JOBS.
THE PUTTING PEOPLE TO WORK
BUILDING THINGS THAT WE CAN BE
PROUD OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN NEGLECTED. THANK YOU FOR THIS COMMITTEE
FOR HEARING US TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER BRIAN. WE HAVE- TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- TESTIFYING
OVER THE PHONE- MEDIA YOSHI
TANI. AND IGN ASIO GOT THE
ADDRESS. OPERATOR Q. PLEASE.
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN. WITNESSES
YOUR LINES ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON.
EXCUSE ME IS THIS. IGNAZ YOGA
THE ADDRESS FROM SCOPE THIS
SEGMENT YEAH THIS IS NOTHING
WITHIN A CYCLE OF PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY HELLO MY NAME IS
CIGNA FIELD AND I'M A MEMBER
COMMUNITY LEADER AT SCHOOL.
SCHOOL BOARDS TO BILL QUESTIONS
POWERS IN SOUTH LA AND CREATE
SYSTEMATIC CHANGES FABRICATING
FOR RACHEL. RAY SHOW- AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE. I AM NOT MY
WRITTEN HERE ABOUT THE NAY AND-
IF SUPPORTERS AB TWO TWO FOUR
ONE NINE BECAUSE WE NEED A- BOB
PARK IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND NINE.
THE ONE FIFTY WAY TO RUN THROUGH
TO OUR NEIGHBORHOOD. AND WE GET
THE POLLUTANTS FUNDS FUNDED A
THREE WAY AND NOT TO SCHOOLS ARE
NEARBY. SO I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO FOUR ONE NINE. THANK YOU AND
HAVE A GREAT AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR RELAXING MEETING
MEMBERS MY NAME TO BE A U. S.
ATTORNEY AND A STRATEGIC ADVISOR
AND FORMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WITH THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK EVEN FIGHT
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE FOR
ASIAN AMERICAN IMMIGRANT REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES AND IS A CO SPONSOR
OF AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN
ALONGSIDE CALIFORNIA GREEN NEW
DEAL COALITION SCOPE WE JUST
HEARD FROM AND GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE. I ALSO SERVE ON THE
WHITE HOUSE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WHETHER WE JACQUI AS A COLLEGE
WHICH IS CHARGED WITH PROVIDING
ADVICE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ON A WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH TO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE INCLUDING
ON JUSTICE FORTY. FORTY IN THE
FEDERAL INITIATIVE THAT OPENS UP
A HUGE OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE
EQUITY IN ECONOMIC AND CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS HOWEVER ADVOCATE HAS
RECOGNIZED THE START THAT STATES
ARE GOING TO BE CRUCIAL FOR
MAKING JUSTICE FORTY REVEALED
UNITY IS ON THE FRONT LINES OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND FELL
INTO THE CLIMATE CRISIS YES IT
FORTY REQUIRED THAT 40% OF
FEDERAL CLIMATE INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING PROVIDE DIRECT BENEFITS
TO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR CALIFORNIA TO
USE THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS COMING TO OUR
STATE TO ACHIEVE THAT CHIEF
JUSTICE FORTY AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETEEN INSURANCE CORRECT
BENEFIT TO FRONTLINE COMMUNITY I
CODIFYING THE JUSTICE FORTY
COMMITMENT INTO LAW WITH AN
ADDITIONAL 10% TOO LOW INCOME.
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE. AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY ALSO INSURE
NEEDS ARE CREATING. FAMILY
SUPPORT UNION WHENEVER. A TWENTY
FOUR NINETY OF THE CREATION OF
CAN THAT ARE. AND WORKER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IN THE USE OF THE TRAVELS AND
ENSURE THAT INVESTMENTS ARE USED
TO ACHIEVE GOALS. CALIFORNIA WAS
ONE OF THE BOTTLES OF THE
FEDERAL JUSTICE FORTY
INITIATIVE. NOW AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETEEN ENSURE THAT WE SEIZE
THIS HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY TO
INVEST IN THE COMMUNITY TO NEED
IT THE MOST. AND CREATE A MODEL
OF INFRASTRUCTURE AS THE BASIS
FOR BOTH COMMUNITY RESILIENCE IN
THE FACE CLIMATE THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AND A MORE JUST AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA. EIGHTY
THREE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR.
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES REGISTERED FOR
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL OPEN IT UP
FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN WILL START
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEE NON-
OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN. IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOR AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN.
ENTER AT THIS TIME WE DO OF
ABOUT TWENTY TWO IN OUR QUEUE.
THAT WILL FIRST START WITH
NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
NUMBERS NUMBERS THAT THE
TRANSCRIPTS CONSULTING ON BEHALF
OF THANK HIGH EIGHT TEN AND VOTE
SOLAR IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEXUS
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME
IS JENNIFER TANNER ON BEHALF OF
INDIVISIBLE CAL'S- CALIFORNIA
GREEN TEAM WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE- IF YOU DON'T
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TEXAS NUMBER
THIRTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME IS
ERIN WOOLLEY ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN. NUMBER.
EIGHTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS DOESN'T WORK MUCH
OF WHAT THE CONTACT CENTRE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETEEN THANK YOU. NUMBER.
TWENTY ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT. CHAIR NUMBER FINALLY HAVE
A DOUBLE AND WITH A NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. NUMBER.
TWENTY SIX. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VERONICA BY THE EXAMPLES
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COMPUTER
PULL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF APRIL. TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN. NUMBER
EIGHTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS SUMMER HERNANDEZ DIRECTOR
POLICY AND PARTNERSHIPS AT THE
TOP OF HUNDRED OF TRANSIT
EMPOWERMENT ZONES AND WE'RE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR. NINETEEN THANK YOU. NUMBER. EIGHTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ADAM
DIAZ ON BEHALF OF THE CESSATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
AQUA APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN HOWEVER WE
DO HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL. I'M
EXECUTIVES OUTLINED OUR CONCERNS
VERY QUICKLY- OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN IS THE DEFINITION OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY IN AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN WHICH IS
VERY NARROW ND LEAVES OUT MANY
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- BUT
PARTICULARLY ALMOST ALL
COMMUNITIES NORTH OF SACRAMENTO
WOULD BE LEFT OUT OF THE
DEFINITION OF THIS BILL- AS YOU
KNOW USER ACCOUNT BY RICH GREEN
DEFINITION OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY WHICH- REALLY FAILED
TO IDENTIFY COMMUNITIES THEY'RE
STRUGGLING. TO MEET WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS. URBAN WATER
RESOURCES AND STATE WATER BOARD
USE THE PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE
DEFINITION. I WHICH IS NOT
ALLOWED THEM TO DIRECT FUNDING
TO THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
MORE LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE WATER
QUALITY ISSUES. I'M IN ADDITION
THIS BILL- WELL WHAT SEEKS TO
BUILD ON PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
JUSTICE FOR INITIATIVE. I'M THIS
BILL WOULD MANDATE 40% OF
FUNDING FROM THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOBS ACT. WELL
THE FEDERAL EFFORT IS A GOAL
ONLY. THE FEDERAL AGENCIES ARE
STILL IDENTIFYING HOW THIS GOAL
SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED AND TO
FURTHER COMPLICATE MATTERS THEY
HAVE YET ANOTHER DIFFERENT
DEFINITION OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY. I'M SO YOU KNOW THIS
BILL REALLY GET THE HEAD OF THAT
FEDERAL PROCESS YOU COULD HAVE A
SITUATION. WHERE IF IT MOVES
FORWARD CALIFORNIA IT COULD BE
DIRECTING FUNDING TO
COMMUNITIES. THAT MAY NOT EVEN
SATISFY THE FEDERAL GOAL. WE
WOULD HOPE THAT THIS BILL WOULD
BE AMENDED TO ALIGN WITH THAT
FEDERAL PROCESS WHICH IS
ONGOING. I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE OTHER OFFICE OFFICE ON
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
BILL DID NOT. LEAVE OUT SO MANY
STRUGGLING COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. NUMBER FORTY FIVE. A GOOD
AFTERNOON VALERIE COUNTRY HADN'T
A VOLUNTEER WITH THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA ACTION AND WE SUPPORT AB.
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN. NUMBER
FORTY TWO. HELLO THIS IS CHERYL
JULIO SACRAMENTO VALLEY CHAPTER
AT THE CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
IN SUPPORT. NUMBER. TWENTY
EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS HEIDI
HARMON AND I'M WITH LET'S BRING
CALIFORNIA AND THE FORMER MAYOR
OF SAN LUIS OBISPO AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETEEN. NUMBER. TWENTY NINE.
HELLO MY NAME IS DON IS GOOD
DOLLARS I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE LIBERTY HEALTH FOUNDATION
THE BILL OF THE PUBLIC
FOUNDATION SERVING L. A. COUNTY
FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX ABOUT
SOCIAL EQUITY ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE WE BELIEVE AB TWO FOUR
NINETEEN WILL BOAST OF THE
WORKER FROM NINE BY PARKING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO POINT NINETY.
THANK YOU. NUMBER FIFTEEN. HELLO
THIS IS DR JOHN CONNOLLY CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ROMERO
INSTITUTE IN SANTA CRUZ AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETEEN. THANK YOU. NUMBER.
THIRTY TWO. HI THIS IS BACK LIVE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA GREEN NEW
DEAL COALITION CALLING I WAS
TRYING TO SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETEEN. NUMBER SIXTY ONE.
SH ONE RECORD BETTER WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORTED AB. TWENTY FOUR
NINETEEN. NUMBER SEVENTY THREE.
HI MY NAME IS CARAMEL MAN I LIVE
IN ALBANY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB TWO FOUR ONE NINE. NUMBER.
TWELVE HI THIS IS MARIO COULD
TRANSMIT PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NUMBER FIFTY. HI
THIS IS POUNDS FELLOW-
REPRESENTING THE POINT MELATI
ALLIANCE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB. TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN. NUMBER
SEVENTY TWO. HI MY NAME IS DAVID
BOWMAN AND BYRON HELP SCIENTISTS
FROM ALBANY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN. NUMBER. THIRTY SEVEN. HI THIS
IS STEPHANIE TIED WITH RISING
SUN CENTER FOR OPPORTUNITY AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN THANK.
NUMBER. TWENTY SEVEN. HI THIS IS
GOING TO BE A CALLING ON BEHALF
OF COSTA AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB. TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN. NUMBER
THIRTY. HI THIS IS MELISSA GREEN
MONEY INSTITUTE COSPONSORED AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN ACCORDING.
NUMBER. EIGHTY I'D LIKE TO THINK
OF ADEQUATE SCOPE AND LANE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
NINETEEN. THE MANAGER AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE. THANK YOU- I'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
WHAT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN THANK YOU
FOR TALKING WITH ME ABOUT YOUR
GOALS FOR THIS BILL I THINK WE
AGREE ON MOST OF EVERYTHING YOU
WANT TO ACCOMPLISH. UNFORTUNATES
WE TALKED- THE BILL USES THE
ENVIRO SCREEN- WITH DEFINITION
OF DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR ME. THAT'S
COOL HEAVILY WEIGHTED AIR
QUALITY TO IDENTIFY WHICH
COMMUNITIES QUALIFY. AND THAT
DISADVANTAGES THE ALREADY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT I
REPRESENT- ALTHOUGH A NUMBER OF
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS APPROPRIATE
USE THAT TOOL TO DRIVE RESOURCES
TO CLEAN UP EMISSIONS AND OTHER
AIR QUALITY CONCERNS. THE
PROGRAM YOU PROPOSE IS MUCH
BROADER THAN THAT. IT EXPLICITLY
BECAUSE OF RESOURCES DEDICATED
TO WATER. INFRASTRUCTURE CLIMATE
CHANGE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
EVEN BROADBAND. I NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE EXPAND BROADBAND MY
DISTRICT HAS BEEN A FOCUS OF
MINE FOR THE ENTIRE TIME I'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE. BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING REBUILD
HOUSES INFRASTRUCTURE AFTER
WILDFIRES WHICH WE HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED IN MY DISTRICT.
ADDRESS C. LEVEL RISE. THREE OF
THE FIVE COUNTIES I REPRESENT
HAVE POVERTY RATES OVER 20% AND
ONE HAS THE LOWEST PER CAPITA
INCOME IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THIS BILL FURTHER
DISADVANTAGES THOSE COMMUNITIES.
WE DESPERATELY PUBLIC DOLLARS TO
HELP BUILD MAINTAIN AND RESTORE
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT MY
DISTRICT AND ALL THEY PREDICT
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO. WITH
THE BILL. I'D LIKE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU BUT I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. SO IN
THE BILL- AS WAS MENTIONED TO
YOU TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF WE
HAVE ALSO CARVED OUT 10% FOR LOW
INCOME SPECIFICALLY IRRESPECTIVE
OF CALABAR WAS GOING. WHICH
MEANS IT'S AN AREA THAT HAS THE
LOWEST PER CAPITA IN THE ENTIRE
STATE WOULD. MOST ASSUREDLY
QUALIFY WE ALSO MAJORED REPLACE
THIS IN THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL THAT THERE ARE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE GUIDELINES TO HELP.
BRING COMMUNITIES BECAUSE WE
KNOW LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES ALSO
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS THE STATE
RESOURCES. AND SO WE MOVED AWAY
FROM THE VIRUS GOING FOR
PORTION. OF THIS ALLOCATION 10%
TO MAKE SURE THAT JUST POOR
COMMUNITIES OUT RIGHT. AREN'T
LEFT OUT JUST BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE POOR AIR QUALITY OR DON'T
HAVE POOR WATER QUALITY OF
WHATEVER METRICS
DISPROPORTIONATELY WAY.
CALAVERAS GOING. APPRECIATE THAT
OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. I
WOULD ARGUE THAT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE DISADVANTAGED
AND LIKE I SAID IN MY DISTRICT-
CALAVERAS GREEN REALLY
DISADVANTAGES US LIKE SO I
THAT'S THAT'S THE CHALLENGE I
HAVE SET UP THE PHONE AND
RESPECTFULLY LOW INCOME IS ALSO
ONE OF THE METRICS THAT INCLUDED
IN CALAVERAS SCREEN IT'S
ACCUMULATIVE SCORE. YEAH AND THE
PROBLEM IS IF WE HAVE GOOD AIR
QUALITY AND WE HAVE CLEAN WATER
THAT MEANS WE DON'T GET
ANYTHING. THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THAT'S A PROBLEM ON ON PRETTY
MUCH. EVERY EVERY EVERY FACET OF
THAT. AND I SO APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO I ABSOLUTELY
DO AND I DON'T DISPUTE THAT AT
ALL BUT- JUST GET OVER SOMETHING
THE DISADVANTAGES. ARE READY TO
SERVE AS COMMUNITY. ABSOLUTELY
NOT BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU TO
FIND ADDITIONAL METRICS BESIDES
LOW INCOME- IF THEM AS A BETTER.
TOOL THAT YOU WOULD RECOMMEND-
BUT THE ENVIRO GREEN AND THE
COMBINATION OF LOW INCOME I
THINK IT'S- THE OVERWHELMINGLY
MAJORITY OF DISPROPORTIONATE
COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. RULE AND URBAN- BUT I'D
LIKE TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
YOU OF COURSE. I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OF MISPERCEIVED-
THANK YOU SO I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THIS SETS ASIDE A
PERCENTAGE AND THERE'S STILL A
LARGE PART PART OF THE PIE THE
MAJORITY OF IT THAT GO ANYWHERE
ACROSS THE STATE BUT OUT THERE
ANYTHING SOMETIMES HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WE GET INTO WHAT I CALL
THE OPPRESSION OLYMPICS OF WHO
HAS IT WORSE WE- A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES NEED TO AT HAND UP
AND A LOT OF COMMUNITIES UP AND
DOWN THE STATE HAVE BEEN LEFT.
OUT OUT THERE. BUT THE REALITY
IS THAT THERE'S A LARGE
PROPORTION OF. COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE CONCENTRATED WHERE WE
HAVE. AIR WATER SOIL ISSUES OUT
THERE AND IT'S AT THAT MUCH MORE
MAGNIFIED OUT THERE. AND SO I
KNOW AT TIMES THE FRUSTRATION
WITH THE CALAVERAS UNIBODY DO
THINK IT'S A FAIR TOOL. OUT
THERE I THINK WHEN YOU START TO
POINT OUT 10% FOR LOW INCOME
YOU'RE TRYING TO. BE INCLUSIVE
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ALSO BEING LEFT BEHIND FOR OTHER
REASONS- THAT MIGHT NOT INCLUDE
ERR. OUR WATER BUT OTHER REASONS
THAT ARE ALSO IMPORTANT SO I DO
APPRECIATE. WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE- I OFTEN SAY THAT-
LET'S FIGURE OUT THAT THAT PIECE
BUT THEN AT THE END THE DAY I'D
LIKE TO SEE MUCH MORE THAN THIS
PART OF THE PIE GOING TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO DEFINE THAT.
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS THAT THEY
ARE BEARING. THE MAJORITY A LOT
OF IT OF THE BURDEN OUT THERE
AND HAVE BEEN FOR A REALLY LONG
TIME AND SO- I'M HAPPY TO COOPER
IS I'M HAPPY TO VOTE FOR THIS
TODAY AND I THINK CONTINUES. TO
MOVE AND I'M NOT ASKING YOU TO
CHANGE THE PERCENTAGE I TO
HIGHER BUT I DO THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WAY I NEED TO
POINT OUT ON A REGULAR BASIS
THAT. I THIS IS JUST A STARTING
POINT IN THE FLOOR NOT THE
CEILING OF WHAT THESE
COMMUNITIES NEED. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY I THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING
OF THIS MEASURE- I APPRECIATE
YOUR DEDICATION TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- I SHARE THAT
PASSION WITH YOU TO MAKING SURE
THAT DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
GET WHAT THEY DESERVE- FROM
FEDERAL FUNDING ESPECIALLY- I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
DEFINITIONS AND WHO QUALIFIES
I'M INCLUDING- YOU KNOW STAYED
UP TO DATE ON WHATEVER THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- IS DECIDING
ON JUSTICE FORTY WHICH I KNOW
THAT. IT'S STILL IN DEVELOPMENT-
SO THANK YOU AND ALSO I WANT TO
ASK IF YOU WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE PROPOSE I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
OKAY THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ABSOLUTELY IN ADDITION TO
EXT ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS I
WANNA PUSH BACK ON SOMETHING
THAT WAS SAID OVER THE PHONE
LINES. THIS IS NOT A MANDATE
THIS IS A THE GUIDELINES FROM
THE COMMISSION OUR
RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE OF THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO BE NIMBLE WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT AS WE
KNOW FAR TOO OFTEN- CALIFORNIA
LEADS THE COUNTRY. IN SO THERE'S
NO REASON FOR US NOT TO HAVE OUR
VOICE HEARD IN THIS DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW IT SHOULD BE DONE- AND
SO BY HAVING A COMMISSION THAT
RECOMMENDS WHAT 40% DISADVANTAGE
COMMITTEES TO LOOK LIKE I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR
CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION. TO MY
COLLEAGUES LOS ANGELES IS POINT
OF BELL GARDENS POINT. IF WE
DON'T MAKE THE INVESTMENTS WITH
NEW MONEY TO TRY TO REMEDY
SYSTEMIC HARMS OF HISTORIC
NEGLECT AND DIVESTMENT. WE'RE
NOT EVEN READY TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT WE DO
WITH EXISTING RESOURCES AND SO I
WOULD URGE THIS COMMITTEE. TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER BRYAN. OF THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED. TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS. I HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER MATHIS I BELIEVE I NEED A
SECOND. SECOND BY MISS GARCIA.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. JERRY THIS AYE RIVAS HI
FLORA. LEARN FRIEDMAN GARCIA.
GARCIA AYE MATHIS. NOT VOTING
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MINUTES EACH YEAR I SEYARTO NO
C. R. TO NO STONE. STONE I WOULD
. NOBODY. OKAY OKAY THAT BILL
HAS FIVE VOTES WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. WE WILL GO BACK. TO
BUY ORDER WE WERE ALREADY ON
NUMBER FIVE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AB TWO TWO FIVE ONE WOULD
REQUIRE CAL FIRE TO DEVELOP A
STATE WIDE STRATEGIC PLAN TO
ACHIEVE A 10% INCREASE OF TREE
CANOPY COVER IN URBAN AREAS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. CLIMATE
CHANGE IS A TESTIFIED HE
CONDITIONS IN OUR STATE'S URBAN
AREAS. TREE CANOPY COVER IS A
TYPE OF GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT CAN PROVIDE OUR CITIES WITH
COOLING EFFECTS AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT AND OVERALL HEALTH
BENEFITS. THIS LEGISLATION WILL
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A BLUEPRINT
TO PROPEL THE FUTURE GROWTH AND
PROTECTION OF TREE CANOPIES AND
ARE WARMING CITIES. I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL AND I'LL BE TAKING ALL OF
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS NOTED AND THEN
ALICE'S. WITH ME ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO FIVE ONE
IS ALFREDO ERA DANDO ON BEHALF
OF TREAT PEOPLE. THANK YU
OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE. FOR OUR WITNESS IN SUPPORT. A GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY THE
KING COMMITTEE MEMBERS LEADING
TO THE PROBLEM BUT NOT PROVIDING
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWO FIVE ONE ON BEHALF OF THREE
PEOPLE. I TREAT PEOPLE WITH THE
LARGEST INTERNAL NON PROFIT
BASED IN LA THAT IS DEDICATED TO
ENGAGING COMMUNITIES TO COME
TOGETHER TO PLANT AND CARE FOR
TREES- AND L. A. COUNTY AND
SURROUNDING COUNTIES. WHETHER
PLANTING TREES AND SIDEWALKS
PARKS SCHOOLS- AND BEYOND A
TREATABLE ENGAGES COMMUNITIES
WITHIN CONTROL FOCUS ON ENSURING
THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THAT HISTORICALLY
BEEN THE COLLECTED. OUR MOST
BENEFIT FROM INVESTMENTS. IT'S
FOR THIS REASON A PARTICULAR
THAT TREAT PEOPLE CONSIDER THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN AND COMMUNITY
FORESTRY PROGRAM TO BE
EXCEPTIONAL SCHOOL. IN MAKING
INVESTMENTS FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED THE EXPANSION A CREEK
CANNOT BE LAUNCHED. WITH AMONG
THE BEST TRACK RECORDS OF
DIRECTLY BENEFITING DISPENSED
COMMUNITIES THIS PROGRAM IS
ALREADY CONSIDERED A MODEL OF
MEANINGFUL. COMMUNITY INVESTMENT
. SO MUCH SO THAT TWENTY FIRST
WILL. HAD SUCCESS IN YEARS
INSURED WHAT WE- ARE DEDICATED
TO HELPING AND INCREASE WE- IN
COMMUNITY. IT IS VERY THOUGHTFUL
AND MUCH NEEDED AUGMENTATIONS TO
URBAN COMMITTEE FORTUNE PROGRAM
. THEN ON THE POLICY FRONT.
EIGHTY TWO TO FIVE ONE FORWARD
OF PUT IT UPDATE THAT WILL
IMPROVE AN ALREADY EXCEPTIONAL
PROGRAMS. IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
TO SOLVE PUT MORE DIFFICULT AND
COMPLEX CHALLENGES THAT THE NEXT
DECADES WILL PRESENT WILL DOUBLE
COMMUNITIES AS A RESULT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. ENSURING THAT AN
OVERALL PLAN OF ACTION TO
SYSTEMATICALLY INCREASED CREEK
COUNTY DEVELOP THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL IS GONNA BE A CENTRAL CORE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES NORTH OF
GOVERNMENTS. TO BE PRESENTED
WITH THE BEST TOOLS TO SOLVE FOR
WHAT CRITICAL AND SOME MEMBER
CALDERON NO OR SOME OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES. IDENTIFYING
RELEVANT RESOURCES TO COMPLETE
THE WORK MAINTAINING TREES AND
CANOPY IN LIGHT OF INCREASED
INCREASING AND THE BIG SPRING
HE- AND OTHER WEATHER EVENTS AND
STRESSORS. AS WELL AS OVERCOMING
ANY OBSTACLE SO SEATED WITH NOT
LOSING OVERALL TREE CANOPY IN
COMMUNITIES- AND BY MENTIONING
THAT AB TWO TWO FIVE ONE EIGHT
CONSISTENT WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM NUMEROUS STATE RESOURCE-
REPORTS. INCLUDING SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA AND THE FORCE CARBON
ACTION PLAN. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WHY WE THINK IT'S ONLY
BURKE CALDERON FOR BRINGING THE
THREAT REPORT AND WE ASK. YOU
FOR YOUR AYE LOOK. THANK YOU. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY WITH. REGISTERED
OFFICE. SO GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT
UP FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY ONE. I'LL START IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
. SECOND ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. I'M SURE AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. K. C. NINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. NEED
A MOTION. CAN WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER MURATSUCHI SECOND BY
MR MCCARTY- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS JERRY THIS HI
RIVAS HI FLORA. THE FLOOR NOT
VOTING FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I SEE YOUR TOTAL
NUMBER. SIRJAN UPLOADING STONE
STONE I WOULD. WOOD I. THE BILL
HAS SIX VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO ITEM NINE- MISTER
KALRA AB. TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN.
YEAH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS. AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN WOULD ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA POCKET FOR SPANISH IT
IS. A PROGRAM THAT WOULD
AUTHORIZE CALIFORNIA TO
DISTRIBUTE GRANTS FOR POCKET FOR
US TO PUBLIC AND NONPROFIT
ENTITIES A POCKET FORCE ACE IS A
SMALL PLOT OF URBAN LAND THAT
HAS BEEN DENSELY PLANTED WITH
NATIVE PLANT SPECIES. IT IS
DESIGNED ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA
WALKIE METHOD THE STYLO TREE
PLANTING THAT DIRECTS GROWERS TO
STUDY AND EMULATE IN AREAS
NATIVE ECOSYSTEM OVER THE COURSE
OF TWO TO THREE YEARS THE PLANTS
WILL GROW INTO A SELF SUSTAINING
MINIATURE FORESTS. THAT CAN
OFFER A WIDE RANGE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH
BENEFITS SUCH BENEFITS INCLUDE
SERVING AS A CRUCIAL HABITAT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S MANY UNIQUE PLANT
AND ANIMAL SPECIES AS WELL AS
PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT
AND SUSTENANCE FOR CRITICAL
POLLINATORS. ADDITIONALLY BY
EXPANDING NATURE ACCESS TO URBAN
AREAS THIS BILL HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH
OUTCOMES OF TENS OF MILLIONS
CALIFORNIANS. SIZE OF SHOWN THAT
PEOPLE WHO SPEND AT LEAST. TWO
HOURS A WEEK IN NATURE OF MUCH
MORE LIKE TO REPORT GOOD HEALTH
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL WELL BEING.
REPORTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY PLANTED SUCH VERY
PLACES AS BRAZIL INDIA THE
UNITED KINGDOM. AND YOU ARE
HERE- IN BERKELEY AS WELL- THE
BERKELEY PARKING FORESTS WERE
PLANTED CRAIGMONT MALCOLMX AND
KINGS SCHOOLS. THE BERKELEY
NOT ONLY A VIABLE ENVIRONMENTAL
OPTION FOR CALIFORNIA BUT A
NOVEL TOOL FOR EDUCATING
STUDENTS ABOUT ECOLOGY. MY
OFFICE IS ALSO WORK WITH URBAN
GREENING GROUPS TO ENSURE THAT
THE BILL TAKES CALIFORNIA'S MANY
UNIQUE ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS
INTO ACCOUNT. MOST NOTABLY AB
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN GIVES CAL
FIRE THE ABILITY TO ADJUST THE
MILWAUKEE METHOD ACCORDING TO
THE STATE'S ECOLOGICAL FEATURES
AND CHALLENGES. THAT ALSO PLACES
PARTICULAR EMPHASIS ON THE USE
OF DROUGHT RESISTANT NATIVE
PLANTS AND APPROVE POCKET FOR
HIS PROJECTS. FINALLY THIS BILL
DIRECTS CALIFORNIA PRIORITIZE
GRANT APPLICATIONS FOR PROJECTS
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES AT LARGE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE GREEN SPACES. AB
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN SERVES AS A
MUCH NEEDED BEACON FOR THE
EQUITABLE COMMUNITY ORIENTED
ENVIRONMENTALIST MOVEMENT HELLO
SURE THAT URBAN COMMUNITIES ARE
ABLE OF A CAR ACCIDENT WE'RE
ABLE TO BE ACCESSED AND ENJOY
THE MANY BENEFITS OF NATURAL
GREEN SPACES. WITH ME PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY ARE DAN
GOOSSEN CAN'T HELP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IS TO PROVIDE
DIVERSITY AND CINDY BLAINE OF
CALIFORNIA RELIEF. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
JERRY VETTING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR THE CHANCE TO SPEAK AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
FOR PROPOSING- POCKET FIRST
INITIATIVE MY NAME IS DANIEL
GLEASON CAMPAIGN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR THE UNIVERSITY A
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT THAT SERVES
AND CONNECTS NINE TESTS AND
SCIENTISTS AND DECISION MAKERS
AND THE PUBLIC. THANK YOU TO GO
SEE IDEA WAS ESTABLISHED TO
ADDRESS THE PAINFUL REALITY
THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT WHILE
CALIFORNIA IS CELEBRATED AS THE
GLOBAL BIODIVERSITY HOT SPOT
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE BEAUTY AND
BENEFITS OF THIS REMARKABLE
NATURE. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
INEQUITY CONTINUES TODAY EVEN AS
WE BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW LACK OF
ACCESS TO FIX OUR COMMUNITY
ACCESS TO NATURE IMPROVES HEALTH
OUTCOMES IN EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT THE BUFFERS LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AGAIN HE IN DROUGHT
ENHANCES WATER QUALITY AND
QUANTITY AND IT JUST MAKES LIFE
BETTER. TODAY TOO MANY
COMMUNITIES ARE LEFT OUT URBAN
FORESTS IN PARTICULAR POCKET
POOREST CAN ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE BENEFITS. I UP IN RURAL.
WITH LAURIE AGENTS ARE. MY
DAUGHTER IS UP VERY DIFFERENT IN
THE CITY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS IS DISTRICT. I WORRY THAT
THEY ARE MISSING OUT ON
CONNECTING WITH NATURE REFUGE
THAT SAVED ME. RECENTLY A
VISIONARY SCIENCE TEACHER STEPS
FORWARD TO ESTABLISH A POCKET
FOR USING THE MILWAUKEE METHOD.
I DON'T NEIGHBORHOOD MIDDLE
SCHOOL HUNDREDS OF PARENTS AND
KIDS AND NEIGHBORS AND EVERYONE
ELSE TURNED OUT. TO TEAR OUT THE
DECORATIVE LAWN IN PLACE
PURCHASE BABY FOREST. NOW WHEN I
WALK BY WITH MY DAUGHTER THANK
YOU CAN REACH OUT AND GENTLY
TOUCH A LOCAL NATIVE PUTS EACH
PLANT TO SNIFF BELIEVES. THE WAY
PEOPLE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THIRTEEN THOUSAND YEARS. IT'S A
WONDERFUL THING AND I BELIEVE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS DESERVE
THIS CONNECTION TO NATURE ACCESS
TO POCKET FORCE CLOSE TO HOME.
FOR A LITTLE WHILE GUESTS CAN BE
AN EASY AND HEALING PART OF
THEIR DAILY LIVES. TODAY WE'RE
IN A BIODIVERSITY CRISIS. PLANTS
AND ANIMALS BLACK THE HABITAT
THEY NEED TO LIVE AND TO GROW.
AND THE RESILIENCE OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS DIMINISHED. IT'S
CRUCIAL THAT CALIFORNIA TELERATE
THE PACE AT WHICH WE ADDRESS THE
SCARCITY OF URBAN GREEN SPACES.
AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
MARKET FIRST INITIATIVE WITHIN
THE URBAN FORESTRY PROGRAM. TO
SUPPORT PLANTING MILWAUKEE
POCKET FORCED ON PUBLIC LAND
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON SERVING
COMMUNITIES THAT LACK EASILY
ACCESSIBLE GREEN SPACES. I'D BE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BOLD AND
MUCH NEEDED INITIATIVE. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU. TO MOVE IT
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WHAT. WE SHOP MET
CINDY PLANE FROM CALIFORNIA
RELIEF.
SHE ON THE LINE OR IT MAY BE
MUTED. I DO NOT SHOW THE
SHOOTOUT IN THE CALL OKAY. THEY
WILL MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN STARTING IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEE NON OF PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN. HIM FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. IN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AT THIS
TIME WE DO OF ABOUT EIGHT THEIR
QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH NUMBER
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL
MY NAME IS AND WHAT WE ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. NUMBER.
NINETY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS TONY
CURRIE AND I AM HERE IN SUPPORT. NUMBER ONE HUNDRED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MARK
SPENCER MAKER BUT CALIFORNIA
URBAN FORESTRY COUNCIL AND THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE AT
THIRTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU TO
MISTER KALRA FOR THIS BILL.
NUMBER. NINETY SIX. I AM DOCTOR
JEFF THAT BIRD SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOURTEEN OF A TEACHER GOT
IT LOCKED UP BY AND I THINK
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT CLIMATE
BIODIVERSITY BUT THAT THE
WONDERFUL BATTLE RIGHT NOW BURKE
BOB SUPPORT THANK. NUMBER EIGHTY
FIVE. HI MY NAME IS IRENE YOUR
MIND NOW I'M OUT COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR AND EDUCATOR. HI ALL A
PROGRAM OF THE NONPROFIT
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR
HUMAN VALUES I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND BIODIVERSITY
AND I SUPPORT AB TWO ONE ONE
FOUR THANK YOU. NUMBER. ONE OH
TWO. NUMBER ONE OH TWO THE
NATURE NOT- YOU. IT'S OKAY LET
ALONE WON'T BE AT THE TRIBUNAL
IN SUPPORT. NUMBER. NINETY FIVE.
HI MY NAME IS SHIVANI. I AM A
TEACHER FROM A ADVOCATING
FOUNDATION IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION AND I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT BIODIVERSITY AND CLIMATE
CHANGE AND I SUPPORT. EIGHTY TWO
ONE ONE FOUR. THANK YOU. YOU
WANT. HI THERE MY NAME'S BILLY
SURE GRAVES ON THE PARENTS OF
TWO STUDENTS AND BERKELEY DO
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM THAT
MOERAKI FOREST. BUT CERTAIN
ABOUT CLIMATE AND I AM HOPING
FOR EFFORT FOR TO BECOME. ACTIVE
IN THAT IT'S BEEN. WORKING IT
THANK YOU. NUMBER. SEVENTY FIVE.
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE IF YOU'RE
NOT ON MUTE. SORRY BELIEVE ON
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE- HI MY NAME
IS JAY C
CH SO THEY SPOKE EARLIER ON
THE WRONG BILLS SO SORRY ABOUT
THAT I'M IN A PUBLIC MIDDLE
SCHOOL TEACHER FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THE SAME SCHOOL WE FINALLY
GOT A FAR TO THEIR SCHOOL AND- I
LIKE MY DAYS EVEN MORE WALKING
BY THE FOREST EVERY MORNING.
TAKING A LEAD EVERY AFTERNOON
AND OUR PLANET NEEDS. HELLO BUT
KIDS USUALLY ONCE AS SPRING. SO
THANK YOU AND I SUPPORT THE
POCKET FIRST. NO. ONE OH FIVE.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS NEELAM
PATEL AND THE SCIENCE TEACHER
WHO- SPEARHEADED THE EFFORT TO
PLANT THESE SCHOOLYARD FOR IT
THEY WERE THE FIRST OF THEIR
KIND IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO ONE ONE FOUR- I
SEE MY STUDENTS- ELEMENTARY
STUDENTS EVERY DAY FEELING
ANXIOUS ANXIOUS AND DEPRESSED
ABOUT OUR FUTURE AND THIS IS A
SOLUTION THAT VERY PROGRESSIVE
AND SPECIFIC AND IMMEDIATE THAT
GIVE THEM HOPE. THANK YOU.
MANAGER WE CURRENTLY HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MR MESSAGE-
OKAY I'M SORRY. ME MR SAY ART. I
THANK YOU SO. I LOVE THE CONCEPT
OF FORESTS EVERYWHERE WHAT I
DON'T LOVE IS CALIFORNIA'S
PENSION FOR NOT HAVING ANY WATER
. AND THE IMPACTS THAT THIS HAS
IN ADDITION TO OUR ALREADY
WORSENING WATER CRISIS- IT'D BE
EASY TO GET BEHIND SOMETHING
LIKE THIS IF WE HAD A SECURE
WATER SOURCE- BUT WE REALLY
DON'T AND AS SO IT'S HARD FOR ME
IN THE FACE OF. A LOT OF THE
OTHER IMPACTS THAT THAT ARE
GOING ON FROM A WIDER
PERSPECTIVE AND ALSO WHAT THE
ONE QUESTION I HAVE IS WITH
THESE POCKET. POCKET FORESTS. BE
SUBJECTED TO THE SEQUEL PROCESS
BECAUSE I CAN SEE A LOT OF
BENEFIT IF THERE'S ENOUGH OF
THEM- THAT WE CAN KEEP ALIVE. TO
AIR QUALITY AND THINGS LIKE
THAT- AND NOT TO MENTION SOME OF
THE THINGS IS SPEAKERS OF SET-
BUT- TO GET THROUGH A PROCESS
THAT WILL EVALUATE THE WATER AND
DRAINAGE AND RUNOFF AND THINGS
LIKE THAT- SEEMS. LIKE IT FLIES
IN THE FACE OF WHAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WE ALLOW IN
COMES TO THE ISSUE OF DROUGHT
WHICH I THINK IS A REASONABLE
ONE TO CONSIDER- A POCKET FOR
THE THERE ARE OR THEY SHOULD
WATER IN GENERAL AND DROUGHT
MORE SPECIFICALLY- WHAT WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS KIND OF GREENERY
THAT ACTUALLY IS MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE SO IT WAS MORE
SUSTAINABLE BECAUSE POCKET FOR
HIS UTILIZED NATIVE SPECIES ARE
MORE COULD TO HANDLE CHALLENGES
AND BY MITCHELL PAN INCLUDING
DROUGHT EACH POCKET FORCES GROWS
INTO MINIATURE SELF SUSTAINING
ECOSYSTEM THAT PROTECT SELF
CONTROL. THE BILL INSTRUCTS CAL
PART EMPHASIZE USE THE DROUGHT
RESISTANT NATIVE SPECIES AND
APPROVE POCKET FOR US PROJECTS
AND THE BILL GRANTS RECIPIENTS
HAVE A LOT OF FUN PROJECT WITH
MEANINGFUL PARTNERS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION FOR AND A PLAN
FOR LONG TERM MAINTENANCE OF A
POCKET FOURS AND THAT IT DOES
ALSO INCLUDE CONTINGENCIES FOR
SEVERE DROUGHT CONDITIONS AND
FINALLY I'D SAY THAT LOOK
ESPECIALLY PUTTING IT OVER
PAVEMENT OR SOMETHING OR JUST
AND- THAT'S RUNNING OFF INTO THE
INTO THE WATER STREAM AND
EVENTUALLY JUST WASTING AWAY
THIS ACTUALLY ABSORBS WATER IF
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE. A HABITAT OF
THIS NATURE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
KEEPING THE WATER IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND YOU'RE ACTUALLY
GROWING OUR WATER TABLE SO AT
THE END OF THE DAY IT'S ACTUALLY
A GREAT SPONSOR SO TO SPEAK FOR
THE WATER THAT FALLS IN THE
ULTIMATELY OTHERWISE WOULD BE
GOING TO STRAIGHT OUT. INTO THE
SOLAR SYSTEM. MR FOR. THANK YOU
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR SORT OF- BUT
- COMMENTS TO BE SOMEONE CLOSE
TO KILL. HERE AT. BUT IS
INTEREST AS WE TALK ABOUT THE
RURAL COMMUNITY I MEAN OBVIOUSLY
I GREW UP IN A RURAL COMMUNITY.
AND WE'VE GOT GUYS THAT ARE
FOLLOWING LAND- BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE WATER WE'RE JUST
GONNA DOWN THERE WE'RE NOT
PLANTING TREES AGAIN. AND THESE
ARE THE COMMUNITIES WHERE. MY
FOLKS GROW UP THIS IS THEIR
PARK. RIGHT AND SO I THINK AS WE
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS. WORDS
LIKE AROUND HERE TO PAY PAUL
WITH THIS AND I THINK A LOT OF
THIS GOES AWAY IF WE ACTUALLY
HAVE. A STORAGE STRUGGLE WITH
THESE PROJECTS BECAUSE- NONE OF
US ARE SAYING THAT. KID IN
BERKELEY SHOULDN'T. HAVE TREASON
AND PLAY ON GRASS LIKE I THINK
THAT'S SAD THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY
THE CASE. BUT I DO WANNA MAKE IT
VERY VERY CLEAR THAT AS WE
TRANSFER WATER. INTO OTHER
REGIONS THAT COME FROM OUR AREA.
ARE STEALING FROM THE ARSON AS
WELL. AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO
GO AROUND. THE WE DO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO FIX IT SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE ALL OF US TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AND FOCUS ON THAT.
THEN THE OTHER THING IS- THIS IS
A SECOND ON A ROAD WE'VE RECALL
PUT TUNING REQUIREMENTS ON
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT AS WELL. CALIFORNIE
EXISTE UNIQUELY FOCUSED ON
SUPPRESSION AND DO WITH THEIR
SUPER GOOD AT. AND SO I WOULD
JUST BECOME. A LITTLE BIT
CAUTIOUS ON. THE ADDITIONAL TASK
WE GIVE THE CAL FIRE. BECAUSE
WHEN THE STATE. ULTIMATELY IS
BURNING AGAIN WE'RE GONNA NEED
THEM TO BE FOCUSED ON THAT. I
PROJECT THAT I COULD MADAM CHAIR
OF CALIFORNIA ALREADY OPERATES A
GRANT PROGRAM FOR URBAN GREENING
THIS DISTANCE ADDS THIS IS ONE
MORE ELEMENT THAT THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY. COULD COULD QUALIFY
FOR THOSE WHO EXISTING GRANTS.
AND SECONDLY AGAIN- IT I DON'T
THINK IT HAS TO BE I THINK YOUR
POINT IS IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
AN EITHER OR NOT AGREE WHEN IT
COMES TO. A WATER- BUT THE
REALITY IS IN MANY URBAN AREAS
WE LOSE A LOT OF WATER TO RUN
OFF FAR TOO MUCH. THAT
EVENTUALLY IMPACTS THE ENTIRE
STATE. BECAUSE THAT URBAN AREAS
ARE TAKING MORE WATER THAN THEY
NEED. THIS ACTION PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US. TO MAINTAIN
MORE WATER IN THE URBAN AREAS OF
THAT. WOULD HAPPEN TO US OF THE
NEED FOR THE LONG RUN IT WOULD
TAKE TWO TO THREE YEARS TO
CREATE A SUSTAINABLE
ENVIRONMENT. BUT ONCE YOU GET
PAST THAT IS A COMPLETELY
SUSTAINABLE. THE STARSHIPS. I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR.
WORKING ON THIS. BILL LIKE L.
AND I WAS IN A PLANT THINKING
THAT CALIFORNIA ALREADY RUNS AND
URBAN FORESTRY PROGRAM- WORK
WITH THEM REGULARLY IN MY
DISTRICT BUT THE REALITY IS THAT
OFTENTIMES WE CANNOT ACCESS THE
DOLLARS IS ALL WE HAVE LEFT OUR
POCKET PARK AREAS AND PARK AND
FORESTRY AREAS AND HAVING TO BE
CREATIVE. IN THINKING OUTSIDE
THE BOX OUT THERE NOT JUST FOR
THE BENEFIT OF HAVING NATURE
AROUND US BUT WE KNOW THAT
LIVING AMONGST THE CONCRETE THAT
I LIVE IN AND DEFINES MY
DISTRICT WITH SIX FREEWAYS. TO
REVERSE THAT ARE ACTUALLY JUST A
BUNCH OF CONCRETE THAT BOOK AND
MY DISTRICT AS WELL- OUR
CONCRETE IS THE REALITY IS THAT
I LIVE UNDER HIVING ISAAC THIS
ALSO HELPS US WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE WITH A FEW ALLEN AFFECT
THAT OUR CHURCH CONSTANTLY
WORKING ON. AS WELL AND SO I
DON'T THINK IT'S AN EITHER OR I
THINK BEING ABLE TO CREATE
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
APPROPRIATE AND GETS US TO ARTS
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM GOALS
IS WHAT THIS BILL IT IS REALLY
ABOUT AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE INNOVATION OF CALLING
ATTENTION TO POCKET FOREST
INITIATIVES- AND. I'M NOT SURE
WHAT WE HAVE AND THEN A TENER.
BUT I THINK IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR. LIKE MINE-
ESPECIALLY BE THINK ABOUT PAY
YOU BACK THE P. BACK IN THAT
WITH. BROWN FEELS IT WERE ABLE
TO CLEAN UP THOSE BROWNFIELD
EVER EVER TO TURN THEM INTO
THESE POPULAR FOREST WERE ABLE
TO THEN CAPTURE WATER WERE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT MY TABLE WATER
IS HIGHER AND HAVE LESS
POLLUTION- THAT I'M DEALING WITH
THEIR WHICH IS ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT. WE DEAL WITH THIS ON SO
HAVING THIS COMING TOWARD TABLE
WATER. INSTEAD OF RUNNING OFF
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW THE COUNTRY
DOESN'T JUST PUSH THAT AWAY- IS
INNOVATIVE AND SO I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF BENEFITS. OUT
THERE ON THAT- THAT'S THAT IN
THE IN THIS URBAN COMMUNITIES
THAT THE DROUGHT ISSUE- WOULD
ACTUALLY BE BENEFITTED WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND SO JUST
WANTED TO COMMENT ON THAT AND I
LIKE TO BE A CLOTH ON YOUR
ABILITY TO KEEP PLAYERS. THANK
YOU MISTER MATHIS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I JUST CAN'T. GO
UNNOTICED YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR
MADE AN EMERGENCY DROUGHT OR THE
OTHER WEEK AND WENT SO FAR AS TO
SAY YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T EVEN
WATER YOUR LAWN- YOU KNOW
MENTIONING STORM AFTER WE'VE
ACTUALLY PASSED QUITE A BIT A
LEGISLATION OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AIMED AT STORM WATER
CAPTURE IT TO SEIZE THAT WATER
SO IF YOU GET IT BACK INTO THE
WATER SUPPLY- SO TO MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT FOR ME IS KIND OF THE
HERE OR THERE BECAUSE WE'RE
ACTUALLY. MOVING CAPTURE EVERY
LAST DROP WE CAN- MISTER FLORA
AND MISTER SATTAR BRING UP GREAT
POINTS YOU KNOW AND IN MY
DISTRICT WE HAVE LITERALLY- THE
DROUGHT IS SO SIGNIFICANT THIS
IS AFFECTING US AT A AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ALSO IS WE HAVE HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING TURNED
DOWN BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
WATER SO IT'S NOT JUST HURTING A
AGRICULTURAL FARMING STANDPOINT.
WERE FOLLOWING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ACRES WHICH ISN'T
JUST URTING THE FARMER THAT'S-
JOBS. THAT'S ONE IN FOUR JOBS IN
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY BEING
AFFECTED. OVER WATER SITUATION
SO FOR US TO GO BACK HOME AND
SAY HEY. YOU KNOW AND I LOVE THE
IDEA OF THE PARK FORCES IT'S
GREAT. BOY WHEN WE'RE IN THE
THIRD YEAR- OF THE DROUGHT. WHEN
WITHIN THE LAST YEAR YOU KNOW
THE DROUGHT THAT WAS HAPPENING.
YOU KNOW NOT EVEN TEN YEARS AGO
WAS SUPPOSEDLY THE WORST DROUGHT
WE'VE EVER SEEN BUT NOW WE'RE IN
THE THIRD YEAR OF AN EVEN WORST
DROUGHT. SHELL CAN YOU EXPLAIN
HOW THIS IS GOING TO BE
SUSTAINABLE. YOU KNOW YOU CAN
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT HOW YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA HAVE DROUGHT
PROOF. FORCED OUR PLANET BUT
THEN. ARE THOSE HYBRIDS REALLY
TRULY NATIVE- HOW HOW'S THIS
GOING TO WORK YOU KNOW IN THE
POINT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS TO.
YES CAL FIRE HAS AN EXISTING
PROGRAM. WELL WHAT IS THEIR
FOCUS TRULY NEED TO BE. BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT YOU
KNOW WHEN IT RAINS ACTION IN
YOUR DISTRICT. UNOPENED INTENDED
TO THE AUTHOR- IT AFFECTS PEOPLE
THAT AFFECTS THE QUALITY OF
LIFE. WE CAN'T REALLY GO HOME
AND SAY HEY WE'RE PROTECTING THE
ENVIRONMENT WE'RE PROVIDING YOU
KNOW BETTER LIFE OUTCOMES. WHEN
THE FACT IS OUR PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE WATER IT'S RAINING ASHES ON
THEM IN THIS IS PULLING
RESOURCES AWAY FROM. SO HOW CAN
MY COLLEAGUES AND I EXPLAINED
THAT TO OUR COMMUNITIES THEY IN
THE VALLEY TO SUPPORT SOMETHING
THEY THINK YOU SEVEN MEMBER
THERE ARE IS AN EXISTING COPPER
URBAN AND COMMUNITY FORESTRY
GRANT PARK PROGRAM WHICH I WOULD
ARGUE RIGHT NOW THE FACT THAT
THE THOSE FUNDS ARE BEING USED
FOR TREE PLANTING FOR EXAMPLE
LONGSTREET'S SPACED OUT TREES-
IS ACTUALLY LESS- LESS
PRODUCTIVE USE A WATER PARK OF
COURSE ARE STAYING WITHIN TWO TO
THREE YEARS AND SO THE REALITIES
EVERY GALLON OF WATER WE CAN
SAVE IN URBAN AREAS IS ONE MORE
GALLON THAT BECAME TWENTY YEAR
COMMUNITIES. RIGHT NOW SO MUCH
RUN UP AS MUCH WATER IS WASTED
IN URBAN AREAS POCKET FOR US HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY ACTUALLY CAPTURE
THAT WATER AND IT IS THE END NOT
ONLY THATBUT IN PLACES LIKE SAN
JOSE WE ARE PURPLE PIPES WE HAVE
RECYCLED WATER THAT'S NOT
POTABLE BUT WOULD ABSOLUTELY BE
FUNCTIONAL BUT THEIR FUNCTION
FOR INDUSTRIAL PURPOSES WILL BE
FUNCTIONAL FOR THIS AS WELL SO
WE CAN USE RECYCLED WATER IN
ORDER TO CREATE THAT FIRST TWO
THREE YEARS OF STAYING ABILITY
AND THEN ASSISTING ABOUT THEIR
ON. GOING FORWARD AND THAT
DOESN'T THE SCIENTISTS SAY THIS
I'VE BEEN USING NATIVE PLANTS I
BECOME SUSTAINABLE LOOK LOOK
LOOK MORE INTO THE QUALITY PART
PER BILLION PERCENTAGE FOR
PURPLE HEART PIPE VERSUS A
BOTTLE OF WATER IN THOSE NUMBERS. WILL SURPRISE YOU- BUT IT'S- A
AGAIN WE- IN. SYSTEMS THE CAP.
THAT WAY TO SET UP ON OFF
SYSTEMS. SO YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY NEED TO PLANT TREES
FOR TO CAPTURE. THE SYSTEMS ARE
BEING DESIGNED IT TO CAPTURE
THAT WATER OUT RIGHT. SO THAT. I
DON'T SEE HOW YOU CAN GET TO A
POINT. TO VALIDATE ST. YOU KNOW
DOING THIS IS GOING TO PROVIDE
MORE WATER. IT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
WE HAVE AN INFRASTRUCTURE
PROBLEM. IN THIS STATE. WE NEED
MORE WATER NOT JUST FOR
AGRICULTURE BEFORE ENVIRONMENTAL
NEEDS AN INTEL WE HAVE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
SUSTAINABLE. FOR OUR CURRENT
POPULATION I DON'T SEE HOW WE
CAN DO THINGS LIKE THIS. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
INTRODUCING IN THIS MEASURE-
EXCITED TO SUPPORT IT TODAY LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BELL GARDENS-
MENTIONED ABOUT ALL ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH HERS- MY DISTRICT
IS VERY SIMILAR TO- MIGHT. TO
BELL GARDENS- WE'RE JUST ASKING
FOR. STRAIGHT RIGHT A TREE- IF
YOU DRIVE THROUGH DISTRICTS LIKE
MINE AND I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS
VERY FEW TREES. OUT AND WE'RE
TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO INCREASE THAT TO DEVELOP. AT
THE TREE CANOPY IN COMMUNITIES.
THAT WERE LEFT BEHIND SO THANK
YOU FOR. BRINGING THIS
INNOVATIVE MEASURE AND I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MANJA
USER COMMENTS OF MY CLOTHES BUT
BASS WHEN I VOTE. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. FOR THE- YEAH
. OKAY OF MOTION BY MISTER
MURATSUCHI SECOND BY MR STONE-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS JERRY THIS HI I
FLOOR NO FLOOR NO FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA MATHIS MATHIS MCCARTY HI
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI MATTEUCCI I
SEYARTO NO SEYARTO NO STONE.
STONE I WOULD. THE BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR MESSI MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF. NEXT WE'LL
MOVE TO ITEM TEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
. THANK YOU YEAH OF COURSE THANK
YOU MEDICARE MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE IS NARROWLY
TAILORED TO ALLOW THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
BOARDING COMMITTEE MEETING
SCHEDULE TO BECOME MORE
EFFICIENT AND AUTHORIZE THE
BOARD TO START ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM CURRENTLY
BOARD MEMBERS CAN ONLY BE
REIMBURSED UP TO ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DAY FOR ATTENDING
ONE OR MULTIPLE MEETINGS AND
BOARD MEMBERS CAN ONLY BE
REIMBURSED. FOR TRAVEL TO
MEETINGS BY CAR RIDE SHARE
PUBLIC TRANSIT BUT NOT BY
WALKING OR BIKING. AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE WILL CHANGE
COMPENSATION FOR BACK MADE BOARD
MEMBERS ATTENDING MEETINGS FROM
A HUNDRED DOLLARS A DAY TO AND
DOES A MEETING WITHOUT CHANGING
THE YEARLY COMPENSATION CAP OF
SIX THOUSAND. DOLLARS PER YEAR
THE GOAL OF THIS CHANGES
INCENTIVIZE MULTIPLE MEETINGS A
DAY IN ORDER TO DEVELOP THE MORE
EFFICIENT MEETING SCHEDULE THE
BILL ALSO ALLOWS THE BOARD TO
GRIN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM THAT COMPENSATES MEMBERS
FOR BIKING OR WALKING TO
MEETINGS WHICH IS IN LINE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S EMISSION. EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS WITH ME IN
PERSON I'VE ALLEN ABS FROM- BACK
MADE IT ON THE PHONE I HAVE A
THE I'M JOHN BOXERS AS THE
EMERYVILLE MAYOR AND BACK MED
BOARD MEMBER VIA PHONE. ASTER
I'VE OF. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR RIVAS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
ALLEN ABS THE LEGISLATIVE
OFFICER FOR THE BAY AREA AQ M.
D. THE SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE AND THE LOCAL
AIR QUALITY REGULATOR FOR THE
NINE COUNTY SURROUNDING THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY THE AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT BOARD IS COMPRISED OF
TWENTY FOUR ELECTED OFFICIALS
THAT ALSO SET ON EIGHT
COMMITTEES AS WELL AS
REPRESENTING THE DISTRICT AT
OTHER AGENCY AND PUBLIC MEETINGS
SINCE THE SECTION OF THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE WAS LAST AMENDED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE A. Q. M.
B. BOARD AND PUBLIC INTEREST AND
PARTICIPATION IN AIR QUALITY
POLICY HAS SKYROCKETED. AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE EIGHT
KNOWLEDGES THIS INCREASED
RESPONSIBILITY IN INTEREST BY
INCREASING TOTAL DAILY MEETING
COMPENSATION BY ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DAY FROM LOCAL
REVENUES TO ENCOURAGE HOLDING
MULTIPLE COMMITTEE MEETINGS PER
DAY WHICH ALSO ALLOWS FOR MORE
ACCESSIBLE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE ALSO
ALLOWS THE A. Q. M. D. BOARD TO
COME TO CREATE A COMPENSATION
POLICY ENCOURAGING ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION SUCH AS WALKING
AND BICYCLING WHEN REPRESENTING
THE DISTRICT THIS AMENDMENT
ALIGNS WITH REGIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR EMPLOYEE
COMMUTE BENEFITS PROGRAMS IN THE
BAY AREA UNDER EXISTING LAW. TO
FURTHER DISCUSS THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION COMPONENT WE ALSO
HAVE R. A. Q. M. D. VICE
CHAIRPERSON AND MAYOR OF
EMERYVILLE JOHN POWDERS THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU WERE
READY TO HEAR- FROM MISTER JOHN
BADER'S SWITCH I BELIEVE IS ON.
THE PHONE OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR A
WITNESS. THE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEDICARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN
DAUGHTERS I SERVE AS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS IN THE BAY AREA AND
THAT- MISTER ABBAS MENTIONED AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE OUTLINED- THE
GOAL OF DID THIS BILL AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE IS TO
ESSENTIALLY DO TWO THINGS WE'VE
LEARNED IN RECENT YEARS THAT THE
INTEREST IN PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN. ON THEIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
HAS INCREASED DRAMATICALLY AND
DUE TO EXTREMELY LONG MEETINGS
THAT ARE OFTEN NEED TO BE
SCHEDULED ON DIFFERENT DAYS- OUT
OF AWARENESS OF THE NEEDS OF
COUNCIL MEMBERS FROM CITIES
AROUND THE BAY AREA WE'RE TRYING
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
PUBLIC MEETINGS BY PUTTING THEM
ON- CLUSTER DAYS WHERE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AND THEN
PREDICTABLY ALLOW THEMSELVES TO
DO ADVOCACY- ON SINGLE DAYS OF
THE MONTH AS OPPOSED TO EIGHT
SEPARATE DAYS OF THE MONTH WHILE
ALSO- HELPING OUR COMPENSATE
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS WHO HAVE ON
P. POSITIONS IN MANY CASES. TAKE
A FULL DAY OFF TO DO THE
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE WORK ON THE
AGENCY ALSO WANTS TO LEAD WITH
ITS MISSION AND IN IN THAT
REGARD WE ARE LOOKING TO EXPAND
OUR- PROGRAMS RELATED TO ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION- PRODUCER NUMBERS
TO HOPEFULLY DEVELOP A POLICY
INTERNALLY FOR COMPENSATING
ACTIVE ARE TRANSPORTATION
PARTICIPATION IN DISTRICT AGENCY
MEETINGS SOMETHING THAT WE HOPE
TO REPLICATE ENSURE REPUBLIC
AGENCIES AROUND THE BAY AREA TO
MAKE A PUBLIC OFFICIALS MORE.
AWARE AND BETTER STEWARDS OF HOW
THEY PARTICIPATE ENGAGE IN
MEETINGS GENERALLY AT LARGE MORE
I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. YOU HAVE AND I ASKED
HER ABOUT. THANK YOU. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY WITH. READ IN OPPOSITE.
SO GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL WHAT WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION STARTING
IN THE HEARING ROOM. C. NINE
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE. IN FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. I'M
SURE AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN OUR QUEUE THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. HEY C. NINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
DRIVER. KING OF. THE MOTION WAIT
I DON'T. SIT BACK THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BETTER CHANNEL BELIEVE IT IT WAS
GOING TO PREPARATIONS. IF I AM
CHANNEL BELIEVE IT'S TAG FISCAL
. IT IS TAX IT IS NOT THAT ARE
NOT SO IT'S PERFECT. HOLD ON FOR
A SECOND. I I'M SORRY WHAT'S OF
THE- OKAY I BELIEVE IT IS TAGGED
AS FISCAL- BY LEDGE COUNCIL TO
WE WILL UP THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS WE- YEAH WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER FLORA.
IN THE WE NEED A SECOND. SECOND
BY MISS GARCIA- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. JERRY THIS HI
RIVAS I FLOOR LARA AYE FRIEDMAN
GARCIA GARCIA AYE MATHIS. MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MURATSUCHI MITSUBISHI I SAY ARE
TOO HIGH. C. A. R. TO AYE STONE
IT'S KNOWN I WOULD. K. THAT BILL
HAS EIGHT VOTES WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO
ADD ON THANK YOU. MISTER SMITH.
OKAY I WILL GO AHEAD TAKE MISTER
SMITH THANK YOU FOR WAITING
PATIENTLY IN THE AUDIENCE WHO.
SO THIS IS ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY TWO NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND START WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT
TWENTY AB TWENTY TWO NINETEEN.
THE MISSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCE THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD IS TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE HARMFUL EFFECTS
OF AIR POLLUTION. WHY THE
REGULATIONS IMPOSED BY
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
HAVE NOBLE INTENT. AND BENEFITS
FOR CALIFORNIANS MANY OF THE
REGULATIONS IMPOSED BY THEIR
RESEARCH RESOURCES BOARD HAVE
FAR REACHING EFFECTS ON NUMEROUS
BUSINESS INDUSTRIES. EXPRESSLY
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT MIGHT NOT
HAVE A FINANCE FINANCIAL
CAPACITY OR KNOW HOW TO INFLICT
. IMPLEMENT THESE REGULATIONS
THIS IS NOT JUST A FEW AFFECTED
BUSINESSES. IN NINETEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE ROUGHLY A
THIRD OF ALL OF THE STATE WORK
FORCES WERE IN FULL OP EMPLOYED
BY A BUSINESS WITH LESS THAN
FIFTY FULL TIME EMPLOYEES. AB
TWENTY TWO NINETEEN WOULD
REQUIRE ON OR AFTER JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE
MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES TO ALSO BE A
PERSON. WHO REPRESENTS A SMALL
BUSINESS THAT EMPLOYS FEWER THAN
FIFTY FULL TIME EMPLOYEES. THIS
IS A NECESSARY STEP IN HAVING
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
ACKNOWLEDGE RESPONSIBILITIES IT
HAS IN THE ECONOMIC IMPACT ON
THE PEOPLE IN INDUSTRIES THAT IT
REGULATES. FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
AND MY WITNESS TODAY WILL BE
MARK CREEK FILLED WITH A GREATER
HIGH DESERT CHAMBER. THANK YOU
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINE FOR MISTER MARK
CRANFIELD. SENATE BILL THE LINES
OPEN YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CHAIR RIVAS MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARGARET FIELD AND I AM THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO WITH THE
GREATER HIGH DESERT CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. ON BEHALF OF OUR
CHAMBER AND LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
NINETEEN. OUR CHAMBER REPRESENTS
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MEMBERS MANY OF WHICH WERE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE GREATER I
GATHER. PART OF THE WORK WE DO
WITH ASSISTING THESE BUSINESSES
WITH UNDERSTANDING AND
IMPLEMENTING COMPLIANCE THE CARD
REGULATION. BECAUSE OF THIS I
UNDERSTAND FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT
CARDS REGULATIONS CAN HAVE. FOR
EXAMPLE BEING A RULE COMMUNITY
MANY SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES COMMUTE LONG
DISTANCES. VEHICLE EMISSIONS
STANDARDS AND PROPOSALS LIKE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED CAN
CREATE BURDENS ON THESE
INDIVIDUALS. MANUFACTURING IS
ANOTHER MAJOR INDUSTRY IN THE
DISTRICTS SUPPORTED BY MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES AND
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES.
REGULATIONS ON HEAVY VEHICLES
AND DIESEL TRUCKS THAT LASTING
IMPACT ON THE LOCAL ECONOMY AND
MAKE DOING BUSINESS MORE
EXPENSIVE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
ACROSS THE STATE. HAVING A
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD WHO UNDERSTAND
SMALL BUSINESS. CAN LEND THEIR
VOICE TO CARDS REGULATORY
PROCESS ENSURING THAT POLICIES
PASSED BY CART. AND IF IT ALL
CALIFORNIANS FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WE DON'T
HAVE A WITNESS A REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN IT UP FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY TWO
NINETEEN WILL START IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEE NON LET'S MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY TWO
NINETEEN. AND FOR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
SECOND ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. I'M SURE AT THIS
TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN
OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MISS
GARCIA YES I- I APPRECIATE THAT
I APPRECIATE YOUR FOCUS ON SMALL
BUSINESSES I GREW UP IN A SMALL
BUSINESS HOUSEHOLDS- MY SIBLINGS
ARE ALL SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND CURRENTLY THERE ARE SOME
SMALL BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVES
THAT ARE. R. E. J. HARD MEMBER
THIS IS MY BUSINESS OWNER
HIMSELF AND SO HE WOULD.
TECHNICALLY FIT THE REQUIREMENT
YOU YOU'RE PUTTING HERE I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY. WHY YOU
CHOSE THE EDC TO ALSO HAVE THE
BUSINESS REQUIREMENT WAIVER
LEVINE THAT TOGETHER. IS IT
CURRENTLY WAS SMALL BIZ I'M NOT
SHOULD THE BUSINESS MEMBERS THAT
ARE ON- GREECE'S SUPPORT I'M NOT
SURE IF THEY'RE FIFTY EMPLOYEES
OR LESS. IT SAYS THE BUSINESS
OWNERS BUT- SOME OF THE MARBLE
CAN YOU ASK ME WHY WHERE TIENE
THE SMALL BUSINESS COMPONENT TO
THE ECJ SPECIFIC C. AND NOT
SOMETHING ELSE ON THE BOARD.
KERN APPOINTEES REQUIRED OF
THESE TWO ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
APPOINTEES IN EACH. THE SENATE
RULES AND THESPEAKER MY BILL
STILL KEEPS AT REPRESENTATION.
AND UNDERSTANDS THE COMMUNITIES
OF THE STATE THERE ARE MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED.
UNDERSTANDING THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY IN THE PROVIDE INPUT
AND HOW REGULATIONS MIGHT AFFECT
THESE BUSINESSES. WHY WHAT WHY
ARE YOU TARGETING THE E. J.
SEATS ARE NOT SOMETHING ELSE FOR
ADDING TO THE AIRPORT WHY
SPECIFICALLY ARE WE ADDING THIS
EXTRA COMPONENT TO THE AG SEATS
THAT. WE HAVE. I'M JUST TRYING
TO HAVE REPRESENTATION FOR
VOICES THAT DON'T HAVE A VOICE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ON AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
BUT WE DO HAVE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ON THAT FOR THAT HAVE
LESS THAN FIFTY EMPLOYEES
ACTUALLY PHILLY ARE BEING
REPRESENTED PRESENTLY. MAYBE
IT'S NOT GUARANTEED- AND SO. SO
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
THAT I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND OR
READ DOING THAT AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE HEAT OF AN AGENCY
POTENTIALLY. OF NOT JUST TO THE
POINT WE BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE TO HAVE A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER WHO WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT I KNOW THE ANALYSIS
SAYS THAT THERE'S BUSINESS
OWNERS. I AM NOT SURE IF THEY'RE
FIFTY EMPLOYEES OR LESS. SO IF
YOU GET THAT ANSWERED THEM
THERE'S NO. NEEDED FOR THE BILL
YES IF THEY IF THEY WITH
ANSWERS. IT SAID THAT BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE SMALLER
THAN FIFTY EMPLOYEES I REQUEST.
OKAY ARE YOU MISTER SPEAKER
YOU'VE DONE SOLVED WHAT I MEAN
IF I AND I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S NOTABLE THAT YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE SMALL BUSINESS PLACES.
ARE INCLUDED AT THE AIR DISTRICT
AND IN THEORY. THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN DISCUSS I JUST DON'T
SEE IT AT THE EXPENSE OF AN E.
J. C. WHEN WE HAVE. HUNDREDS OF
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
THAT BLACK REPRESENTATION IN THE
SEVEN TWO HARD FOUGHT FOR SEATS
FOR MANY YEARS OUT THERE AND SO.
I WOULD WANT TO SEE A DIFFERENT
WAY TO GET TO YOUR GOAL AND SO
IT'S NOT THAT YOU'RE BOTH A
PROBLEM IT'S- IT'S THAT IT'S
THAT I HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS I
pWOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE. THAT WE
GET THAT ANSWER ABOUT THE
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE AT THEIR
DISTRICT AND- THE SIZE OF THEIR
BUSINESSES- PERIOD FOR. FOR THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. IT APPOINTEE
OF THE IN VAI MENTAL JUST.
APPOINTEE IS A BUSINESS OWNER OF
FIFTY LESS. EMPLOYEES
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WOULD SUPPORT IT
. I THINK THAT LIMITED THAT'S A
REALLY NARROW DEFINITION AND
WITHIN THE EACH A COMMUNITY AT
ADVOCATE THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT NEEDS OUT THERE AND I
HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT ADDING AN
EXTRA REQUIREMENT LIKE THIS ON
THAT TO GET YOUR WILL OF HAVING
SMALL BUSINESS REPRESENTATION.
ON THE BOARD. OKAY MISTER SEA.
OKAY SO IT'S A REALLY WHAT THIS
DOES IS JUST GUARANTEE THAT THEY
HAVE. THE SMALL BUSINESS DOES
HAVE A SEAT AT THE BOARD WHETHER
OR NOT THEY HAVE ONE NOW. IS OF
NO CONSEQUENCE OTHER THAN THEY
GOT LUCKY IN AND HAVE SOMEBODY
THAT'S THERE. THOSE PEOPLE WOULD
BE RAISED AND THEN THERE'D BE NO
REPRESENTATION ALL THIS DOES IS
ENSURE THAT THERE IS RAMPANT IN
TATIAN IS THAT CORRECT YES SIR
THANK YOU. MR STONE. THANK YOU
THIS ABSOLUTELY DILUTES THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
REPRESENTATION ON THE AIRPORT
AND I CANNOT SUPPORT. MR FLOOR I
THINK IN IN THE LANGUAGE OF YOUR
BILL AT THEM IN THE GOVERNOR HAS
TWO APPOINTEES ASSESS THAT
SHOCKING TO SHE CAN'T APPOINT TO
PUBLIC MEMBERS CORRECT SIR SO
CAN BE ONE OF THOSE TWO
POSITIONS THAT THE GOVERNOR
COULD APPOINT YEAH CORRECT. THEY
WHICH DOES NOT NECESSARILY
ATTACKING THE J. SEAT
NECESSARILY NOT AT ALL YOU DON'T
PARTICULARLY CARE WHERE IT COMES
FROM NO. WE JUST WANT A SMALL
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
BOARD OF UNDER FIFTY EMPLOYEES
THANK YOU HAVE A POINT OF ORDER
THE BILL SPECIFICALLY SAYS THE
AJC APPOINTED BY THE SENATE
RULES CHAIR AND I DON'T THINK
IT'S OUR BUSINESS IN THE
ASSEMBLY TO TELL SENATE RULES.
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE APPOINTING
NOR SHOULD WE BE INTERFERING
WITH A HARD FOUGHT ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMPONENT ON THE AIRPORT
AND I'M NOT TAKING ANYTHING AWAY
FROM THE E. J. COMMUNITY. THIRTY
THEY HAVE FOURTEEN APPOINTMENTS
THAT THEY CAN HAVE THEIR I JUST
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
REPRESENTATION FROM SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER LESS THAN FIFTY
EMPLOYEES. ON THAT BOARD. OKAY
MISTER MAKER. YEAH THERE ARE I
THINK A DOZEN OR SO APPOINTEES
ON THIS MANY FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS YEARS AGO WE ADDED
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE BECAUSE
THOSE VOICES WERE NOT HEARD.
LIKENESS GARCIA SAID VOICES IN
THE SOUTHEAST LA THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
VOICES FOCUSING ON ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE DOES MAINLY COME. FROM
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
NEIGHBORHOOD GROUP SECOND REALLY
ATTACHED TO THE ACUTE ISSUES OF
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE WITH OUR
AIR AND SO I GET WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING BUT I 100% ARE IN ACCORD
WITH HERE IF YOU WANTED TO DO
THIS YOU SHOULD ADD ANOTHER SEAT
THAT SAYS THIS ANOTHER SEAT
SHOULD BE A SMALL BUSINESS UNDER
THIS AND THAT. BUT TO TAG ON TO
THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SEATS
DIMINISHES WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
DID ADD THESE ADDITIONAL VOICES
IN ADDITION TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS THAT SERVE
ON THE AIRPORT. IN THE GOVERNOR
COULD APPOINT TWO FOUR FIVE MORE
MEMBERS FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMITTEE COMMUNITY IF
YOU WANTED TO I DON'T I'M NOT
TECHNICALLY I THINK YOU GO BACK
AND LOOK HOW THEY CREATE THIS
BOARD A BUNCH OF THE SEATS ARE
SPECIFIC TO REGIONS I KNOW
THERE'S ONE HERE FOR THE
SACRAMENTO REGION THEN MAINLY.
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND A FEW
YEARS AGO WE ADDED. A COUPLE
AGENCIES WAS THAT- TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY. SO I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS MAKE
SURE YOU WANT TO SMALL BUSINESS
VOICE ON THERE. YOU SHOULD GO
BACK AND ASK ADD ANOTHER SEAT A
NEW C. DON'T CAR ABOUT THE GAC.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY I BELIEVE FOR THE CURRENT
APPOINTEE FROM SENATE RULES
THAT'S R. E. J. C. IS ALSO A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER- AND SO.
CURRENTLY MEETS BOTH
REQUIREMENTS THAT DATA POINT T.
R. BUT WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE
APPOINTEES. OF THAT ARE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS UNDER FIFTY
EMPLOYEES ON THE ON THE BOARD-
BUT I DIDN'T GET THE INFORMATION
BACK TO MY OFFICE THAT THEY'RE
UNDER FIFTY EMPLOYEES. IF THERE
IS I'D LIKE TO KNOW THAT. THAT
THERE ARE THREE. CURRENTLY FROM
ACCORDING TO MY CONSULTANT
LOOKED INTO IT YES THANK YOU.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIBEL OKAY
THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE- DO WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND I'M
SO SORRY. WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
MY MISTER FLORES SECOND BY
MISTER MATHIS. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL JERRY THIS HI
RIVAS HI FLORA FLORA I FRIEDMAN
GARCIA. GARCIA NO MATHIS MATHIS
I MCCARTY. MCCARTY NUMBER CG.
NOT VOTING SEYARTO HI SO YOU'RE
TO AYE STONE. STONE NO WOULD.
NOT VOTING. THE BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. KENEXA MOVED TO
MR HOLDEN. PLEASE. THE ITEM.
EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- FIRST I'D LIKE TO STATE
THAT I'M ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AS
RECOMMENDED AND I LIKE TO THINK
THAT SHARING HER CONSULTANT FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE TEARS CONCERNS WHILE
KEEPING THE SPIRIT OF WHAT I'M
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH IN TAX.
WHICH IS A C. CALIFORNIA MEET
ITS AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEMANDS
BUT NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF OUR
CLIMATE GOALS I ALSO WANT TO
THANK CBI A FOR CONTINUING TO
ENGAGE IN GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS WITH MY OFFICE AND
OUR SUPPORTERS. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY ARE NOW
IN POSITION TO TAKE OUR OFFERED
AMENDMENTS TO THE FULL BOARD FOR
CONSIDERATION A REVISED POSITION
TO THIS BILL. THEREFORE TODAY
I'M PRESENTING AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY SIX A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO
DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK FOR
MEASURING AND THEN REDUCING
CARBON INTENSITY AND THE
MATERIALS USED AND NEW BUILDINGS
INCLUDING THOSE FOR RESIDENTIAL
USES. AS YOU'RE ALL AWARE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN ISSUED EXECUTIVE ORDER B.
FIFTY FIVE EIGHTEEN WHICH ORDER
TO STATEWIDE GOAL T ACHIEVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY. AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. TO ITS CREDIT.
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN THE CHARGE
AND HAS MADE GREAT STRIDES IN
REDUCING ITS CARBON FOOTPRINT.
WITH THE PURCHASE OF OUR
GOVERNMENT. ELECTRIC VEHICLES
NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR LAWN CARE
EQUIPMENT. AND GOVERNMENT AND
RESIDENTIAL RETROFITS FOR ENERGY
SAVINGS. AS THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR NEWSOM SEE CREATIVE
IDEAS AND SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING SHORTAGE
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SIX SEEKS
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE CONTINUING
TO SUPPORT THE DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP. WHILE AVOIDING A
RETREAT AND OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SIX
REQUIRES CC AND CONSULTATION
WITH THE STATE AIR RESOURCES
pSTANDARDS COMMISSION TO DESIGN A
FRAMEWORK TO ACHIEVE AN 80% NET
REDUCTION AND CARBON INTENSITY
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS USED IN
NEW CONSTRUCTION BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. WITH INTERIM GOALS OF 20%
BELOW TWENTY TWENTY LEVELS AND
40% BELOW TWENTY TWENTY LEVELS
BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. THE BILL
CALLS FOR THE FRAMEWORK TO BE
DEVELOPED IN COORDINATION AND
CONSULTATION WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AND EXPERTS IN
ACADEMIA. INDUSTRY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. FINALLY AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY SIX ALLOWS FOR THE
INCLUSION OF TRACKING AND
REPORTING MECHANISMS THAT WOULD
FACILITATE THE ACHIEVEMENT OF
THE GOALS SET FORTH IN THIS
BILL. AND A SYSTEM TO CREDIT.
CARD FOR A SYSTEM OF CREDITS
THAT CAN BE TRADED AMONG PRIVATE
ENTITIES AND WE'RE TRACK THE
TRANSACTION OF THOSE CREDITS.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT-
IS PATTY HARTBERG PATRIDGE
PRINCIPAL AT US WEST COAST
AVIATION LEAD. AND SAND SAM
RUBIN CO FOUNDER OF MIGHTY
BUILDINGS. I WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. OF OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR.
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
PATTY HARPER PATRIDGE AND I AM A
STRUCTURAL ENGINEER AND LEAD
PRINT THE POINT BRO HAPPEN TO
NEARLY A GLOBAL CONSULTANCY FOR
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT AND THE
PUBLIC REALM WHICH NINETEEN
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES IN THIRTY ONE
LOCATIONS WORLDWIDE. I ALSO
SERVED AS PRESIDENT ELECT FOR
THE STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS
ASSOCIATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER ONE
THOUSAND ENGINEERS ACROSS HALF
THE STATE. OF THE NATION THIS IS
AN ISSUE OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO
US. AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY SIX
ISN'T. IMPORTANT IN ADDRESSING
THE CLIMATE EMERGENCY. TO MEET
THE ONE POINT 5 DEGREES C.
CARBON BUDGET. ALL NEW BUILDINGS
AND MAJOR RENOVATIONS MUST BE
DESIGNED TO BE ZERO CARBON TODAY
. NOBODY CARBON OF CONSTRUCTION
MATERIALS AND QUICKLY EMERGED AS
A CRITICAL CONSIDERATION FOR
CLIMATE MITIGATION AND
RESPONSIBLE DESIGN PRACTICE. THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION SECTOR
IS RESPONSIBLE 440% OF GLOBAL
CARBON EMISSIONS UNFORTUNATELY
CURRENT BUILDING CODES DO NOT
TYPICALLY ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF
THE BODY CARBON AND BILLY CAL
THE PRODUCTS. IT FOR SERIOUS
ABOUT MAKING MEANINGFUL CHANGE
WE NEED TO REDUCE EMBODIED
CARBON IN OUR BUILT ENVIRONMENT.
AS A PROFESSIONAL IN THE
INDUSTRY I THINK ABOUT AND BODY
CARBON EVERYDAY- HOBBLED ALONG
WITH MANY OF OUR PEERS IS
COMMITTED TO SB TWENTY FIFTY
CHALLENGE TO MEASURE REDUCE AN
ACHIEVEMENT HEROIN BY THE CARBON
STRUCTURES BY TWENTY FIFTY. MY
COLLEAGUES AND I NOW LOOK AT THE
LIFE CYCLE IMPACTS OF CARBON IT
VERY EARLY STAGES OF THE PROJECT
WE FOUND A STRONG CORRELATION
BETWEEN EMBODIED CARBON AND
STRUCTURAL COST. ME NOT BY
MEASURING AND REDUCING CARBON
EARLY ON WE CAN DELIVER PROJECT
THAT IS BOTH BETTER FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT. AND ALSO MORE
ECONOMICAL. IT IS CRITICAL WE
GET A HANDLE ON A BODY CARBON
NOW IF WE HOPE TO ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
AT THE SIGNERS OF STORAGE OF THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT WITH THE
EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR FORTY SIX AND
A CRITICAL MEASURE NEEDED TO
MAKE MEANINGFUL CHANGE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY SIX WILL PROVIDE US WITH A
FRAMEWORK TO BOTH MEASURE AND
GRADUALLY BEGIN TO MANAGE. THE
BODY CARBON IN OUR BUILT
ENVIRONMENT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS SAM RUBIN I'M THE
CHIEF SUSTAINABILITY OFFICER AND
ONE OF THE CO FOUNDERS MICHAEL.
MIGHTY BUILDING AN OAKLAND BASED
COMPANY UTILIZING NEW THREE D.
PRINTING MATERIALS AND
TECHNOLOGY I'M NOT PRODUCTIVITY
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION WHILE
DROPPING THE CLIMATE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS NEW
BUILDING. AND AT THE SAME TIME
TRACKING. YOUR GENERATION OF
WORKERS IN THE INDUSTRY. WE
REPRESENT A GROWING GROUP
INNOVATIVE READING MATERIAL NOT
FOR THEIR SHIP IN CALIFORNIA. I
WOULD LIKE TO LEARN MYSELF WITH
THE PUBLIC PACKAGING COMING ON
THE TECHNOLOGY. EQUITIES DOWN
THE NEXT TWENTY TWENTY ONE I
REPORT. IN NEW BUILDING PROJECTS
UP 250% OF TOTAL GHG EMISSIONS
OVER THIRTY YEARS BUILDING LIFE
ARE FROM THE EMBODIED CARBON
STRUCTURE. PAID WITH INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION. AND WHAT BUILDING
IT BECAUSE- THE LITTLE THAT CAN
BE DONE TO EVERYBODY TALKING
AFTER THE FOR. WE'RE SUPPORTING
AB TWO FOCUS. BLOCKS ON THAT
STEP IN HISTORY CLIMATE LEADERS
. BUILDING OFF THE WORK HAS BEEN
DONE TO ADDRESS OPERATIONAL
CARBON IN BUILDING WOULD BE
ENTITLED TWENTY FOUR. THE BILL
PEOPLE FOR AND GETTING ADDRESS
THE BODY KERR IN A BUILDING WITH
NOT. HELLO WITH POSSESSING THE
STATE AFFECTED MEASUREMENT THE
AND YOU THE MEMBER BY MENTAL
UPGRADE AND LYFT LIKE. AB TWO
FOUR POSTER WILL ALSO ENTITLE
FIVE DOT OF LOOK MATERIALS
MATHIS. MORGAN OF AND
ECONOMICALLY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GREEN BUILDING MATERIALS. MY
DEVELOPING ANOTHER COMPANIES
LIKE OPPOSITION TO PROVIDE COST
EFFECTIVE LOW CARBON POLLUTION
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING. AB TWO
FOUR FOUR SIX WILL HELP FOCUS
THE HOTWHEELS CARE AND TIRELESS
WORK ETHIC CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS
AND BUSINESSMEN I'M TALKING THE
KEY DRIVER OF THE PINE CREEK. I
ONLY ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
STYLE. THANK YOU. FOR THANK YOU.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES OF
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION SO OPEN
IT UP TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF TWENTY
FOUR FORTY SIX STARTING IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. HIM FOR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE SIX IN OUR QUEUE. WE WILL
START WITH NUMBER. TWENTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL GUNNING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION YOU KNOW I HAVE TO
SHARE WHEN MR HOLDEN'S OFFICE
CALLED AND SAID HEY WE WANT TO
REDUCE CARBON IN CONSTRUCTION
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION I SAID
DON'T WE DON'T YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A HOUSING CRISIS- BUT AFTER
TALKING WITH THE OFFICE AND
WORKING WITH MR HOLDEN- ATTY
SUGGESTED IN HIS OPENING
COMMENTS. WE ARE FINDING THAT
THERE MIGHT BE A PATHWAY HERE
AND WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR SO WE ARE HERE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT- I
DON'T THINK CITED BUT HOPEFUL
THAT WE CAN REACH AN AGREEMENT
HERE SO. THANK YOU. NUMBER. ONE
OH NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE
VICTORIA ROME WHAT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. NUMBER ONE OH SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON CATHY SCHAEFER FOR THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN. GET
BASS ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE COURT.
NUMBER. THIRTY THREE. READ AND
SHARE DR MILAN ON BEHALF OF THE
U. S. GREEN BUILDING COUNCIL IN
LOS ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NUMBER. SEVENTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING MEMBERS
PRETTY CURTAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION BUT WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING IF YOU'RE
ON A BUTTON THANK YOU. VENTURE
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS
IN OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU DO WE
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. A. C. NINE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MANAGER I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT- TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE-
AND NOT JUST FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT TO WIN IS GOING TO
REQUIRE COLLABORATION AND SO I
DO APPRECIATE CBI AS-
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US AND
CONVERSELY OURS WITH THEM. TO
ADDRESS THESE TWO IMPORTANT
PRIORITIES CLIMATE CHANGE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HOW DO WE
DO THAT AND BRING IN MERRITT
THESE TWO EFFORTS TOGETHER-
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX AS WE'VE
BEEN INSTRUCTED TO DO AND TO TRY
TO FIND CREATIVE AND
COLLABORATIVE WAYS TO GET TO
GOAL SO- THIS PUTS US LEASE ON A
PATH TO ALLOW THE C. C. TO START
LAYING OUT THE FRAMEWORK. OF
WHAT- APPROACH LIKE THIS WOULD
TAKE WE CONTINUE TO- WILL WORK
WITH- ALL CONCERNED AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION DENTURES.
I THINK WE'LL MOTION AND A
SECOND. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
JERRY THIS HI RIVAS I FLOOR.
LEARN FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA AYE
MATHIS. MCCARTY MCCARTY I
MURATSUCHI. SEYARTO NO SEYARTO
NO STONE STONE I WOULD. WHAT I.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU. NEXT I
BELIEVE WE HAVE MR TANG AND-
MISS IRWIN WILL BE PRESENTING
WITH HIM. THIS IS ITEM. FIFTEEN
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MADAM CHAIR
SO- AB TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR BUILT
ON A BILL THAT MYSELF. AS A
MEMBER IRWIN DID LAST YEAR
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
RECYCLE FOR REFORMS THE REFORMS
ARE THINGS THAT WE SEE. VERY
CALMLY IN THE SUPERMARKET OF THE
CLAM SHELLS THAT STORE AT
BARRY'S SILENCE TAKEOUT
CONTAINERS YOU CAN YOU CAN
IMAGINE OVERT COVERT HELP ME
PICK UP CONTAINERS WE ALL USED
OVER TIME. WHAT WE REALLY WANT
TO DO IS TO ENSURE THAT THESE
ITEMS ACTUALLY GET RECYCLED
EVERYONE ASSUMES THAT BECAUSE
THEIR PLASTIC THE TERM IN THE
BLUE BIN THEY GET RECYCLED BUT
ACTUALLY THAT COULD BE FURTHER
FROM THE TRUTH BEAUSE THERE'S A
VERY LIMITED MARKET FOR THE
SERVER FORMS- THEY ACTUALLY
DON'T GET RECYCLED QUITE OFTEN
END UP IN LANDFILLS. IT'S OUR
BILL WOULD SET GUIDELINES AND
GOALS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
HAVE 10% RECYCLED CONTENT IN
THESE REFORMS A 20% RECYCLED
CONTENT IN TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
AND 30% BY TWENTY THIRTY AND
THIS BUILT UPON THE WORK THAT
MYSELF AND MR WHEN DID A NUMBER
OF YEARS AGO TO RECYCLE BEVERAGE
BOTTLES SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
AS THE DEMAND FOR RECYCLED
BEVERAGE POLITICS GONE UP. THAT
WE ALSO GET THE REFORMS BE
RECYCLED AS WELL TODAY WE CAN
HAVE A REALLY FULLY RECYCLABLE
PLASTIC- CONTENT COMMUNITY- IN
CALIFORNIA SO WITH THAT I'LL
TURN OVER TO HIM EARLY THANK
YOU- MR TANG AND L. AND AS MR TO
MENTION THIS IS A REINTRODUCTION
OF A BILL THAT VIEW OF VOTED FOR
BEFORE AND BUILT UPON THE ACTION
TAKEN BY THIS LEGISLATURE TO
INCENTIVIZE THE RECYCLING OF.
PLASTICS SO JUST TO MAKE CLEAR
WHAT WE WHAT WE DID WITH THE
BOTTLE BILL IS THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT BEVERAGE BOTTLES
WERE RECYCLED INTO BEVERAGE
BOTTLES WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
NOW IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
REFORMS ARE RECYCLED INTO
THERMAL FORMS BECAUSE IT'S
ACTUALLY CALLED- DOWN. CYCLING
IF YOU. IF YOU. WERE A BOTTLE
COULD BE MADE INTO. OF BUT FORMS
THEN WE'LL KNOW BE ABLE TO BE
MADE AND TWO BOTTLES AND SO WE HAVE. SOME CONCERNS FROM THE
AG INDUSTRY I WOULD HAD A NUMBER
OF CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM AND
WE REMAIN COMMITTED. TO FINDING
A PATH FORWARD AT THIS YEAR WITH
THE BILL- TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TODAY OUR BALLCLUB-
DIED. THE DAVY DUCK. BOB DAVID
AXIO OF OUR PLANET EARTH AND
THERE THE SPONSORS AND MARKET
MARIE WITH CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE. THANK YOU OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OKAY
THAT THANK YOU THIS IS- POPPED
UP- FROM THE CO FOUNDER AND CEO
OF THE COMPANY OUR PLANET EARTH
- OUR PLANET EARTH IS THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH- CLOSE THE
LOOP ON THERMOFORMED CONTAINERS
USED IN FOOD AND BEVERAGE
APPLICATIONS IN CALIFORNIA. WHY
IS THAT WORKING MINIMUM RECYCLED
CONTENT REQUIREMENTS. MY COMPANY
IS THE WORLD'S FIRST COMPLETELY
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED RECYCLER
AND MANUFACTURE. OF RECYCLED P.
E. T. ALSO KNOWN AS OUR PET
PACKAGING AND OTHER PRODUCTS
DERIVED FROM POST CONSUMER BAIL
AT THE PAINTERS. BOTH BOTTLES
AND THERMOFORMED CONTAINERS WHAT
WILL RECYCLING AND TURNING BACK
IN THE NEW PRIMARY PACKAGING
ANOTHER PRODUCT. WE HAVE VERY
EFFICIENT MAKING IT PROCESS-
WHICH GIVES UP THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT THAT IS AMONG THE
LOWEST IN THE WORLD FOR OUR- FOR
THE PRODUCT THAT WE PRODUCE. THE
REPORT CONTAINERS SHOULD CONTAIN
THE MOST CALIFORNIA RECYCLE
CONCEPT. ACTIVE IN THE UNITED
STATES RECYCLE CONTENT HOWEVER
THE PRIMARILY OF RECYCLED
PLASTIC BEVERAGE BOTTLES. AT THE
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY MOVED THROUGH
INCREASED THE- RECYCLED CONTENT
TO COMPLY WITH EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THE PERFORMANCE
THE THREE RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
TRANSITION THE CLOSING THE LOOP
ON THE LOAN FROM THE FORM
CONTAINERS. CONTAINER ARE HIGHLY
RECYCLABLE IMPROPERLY COLLECTED
SORTED AND PROCTER. AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR REPRESENTS A
UNIQUE SITUATION WHERE THE
PERFORMANCE THREE IS
DEMONSTRATING LEADERSHIP WE DO A
NUMBER OF THINGS INCLUDING
ENCOURAGE THE COLLECTION OF
CALIFORNIA PROP THAT PLASTIC
FEEDSTOCK NEEDED TO MAKE SOME
APPOINTED TRAINERS FOR A CLOSED
LOOP SYSTEM. THERE IS A GREAT
HELP OUT EMISSIONS AND LANDFILL
A VERY VALUABLE COMMODITY. SPIKE
IS OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
PROVIDING A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
FOR ALL USERS OF THERMOFORMED
CONTAINERS. WE WANT TO THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHANGE. FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL
HELP THE STATE MOVED TOWARDS ITS
WASTE REDUCTION AND CLIMATE
CHANGE GOAL. YEAH ON THE CLIMATE
FRIENDLY REDUCTION A RESOURCE
USING GREENHOUSE GASES. PLASTIC
RECYCLING GENERATES JOBS AND
ECONOMIC BENEFITS FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. CREATE A CIRCULAR
ECONOMY TO PRODUCE COLLECT
RECYCLE AND PROFITS POSTED WHAT
THE CAMEL FARM CONTAINERS. ON
BEHALF OF EVERYONE OF OUR PLANET
EARTH I'D LIKE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK MURRAY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. LET ME TAKE A SECOND TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIANG AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN FOR THE
PREVIOUS BILL ON RECYCLE CONTENT
BECAUSE THAT MEASURE ON PT
BEVERAGE BOTTLES IS ALREADY
PAYING FINANCIAL DIVIDENDS THE
CALIFORNIA LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
RECYCLERS. WITH RECORD HIGH
SCRAP VALUES FOR THAT P. ET
MATERIAL. THE PURPOSE OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO DO THE EXACT SAME
THING WITH PTP AND OTHER PLASTIC
THERMOFORM PACKAGING. AT THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS SPOKE WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS TECHNICALLY
FEASIBLE WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
COLLECTION INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA ALL WE NEED TO DO
WITH THIS LEGISLATION IS PUT
THOSE TWO THINGS TOGETHER SO-
THIS BILL IS GOING TO CREATE AN
EVEN PLAYING FIELD FOR MAKING
THAT HAPPEN- WE BELIEVE THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECYCLE FORMAL
FORM TO THERMAL FORM. IS GOOD
FOR BOTH THE ENVIRONMENT BOTH
FOR RECYCLING FOR DIVERTING
MATERIAL FROM LANDFILL ASWELL
AS WITH NOTED FOR REDUCING THE
CLIMATE EMISSIONS FROM PLASTIC
PACKAGING WE URGE AND I THOUGHT
. THANK YOU. WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES- IN OPPOSITION ONE I
BELIEVE TESTIFYING IN PERSON
MISTER LOUIS BROWN. FROM CON
SWORDS AND CON WAY AND NEXT-
BRUCE MEG NANI FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF PLASTIC RECYCLERS
WHICH WE TEST FINE OVER THE
PHONE. MISTER BROWN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MANAGER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STRAWBERRY
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA BLUEBERRY
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA APPLE
COMMISSION AND A FEW OTHERS THAT
ARE PROPERLY LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS UP FIRST DO YOU WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHORS FOR THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE HAD EXTENSIVELY LAST
YEAR- OVER THE BILL AND HAVE
STARTED AGAIN THIS YEAR- I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE- AS HAS
BEEN STATED BUT- SPECIFIC AS IT
RELATESTO THE BERRY INDUSTRY.
THE VERY INDUSTRY ENTERED INTO A
NORTH AMERICAN AGREEMENT- TO ON
ITS OWN INCREASE THE RECYCLED
CONTENT USED WITHIN THE CLAM
SHELLS THAT- WE NOW USE WITHIN
THE BERRY INDUSTRY AND THE
TRANSITION TO THOSE CLAM SHELLS
WERE WERE MADE IN PART TO HELP.
WITH STORAGE THOSE CLAM SHELLS
HELP WITH TRANSPORTATION THOSE
CLAM SHELLS HELP REDUCE DAMAGE
OF BERRIES WHICH THEN ALLOW FOR
THEM TO STAY ON THE SHELVES A
LONGER AND ACTUALLY CONSUMERS TO
ACCESS THEM. SO WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THE IDEA OF INCREASE
RECYCLED CONTENT BECAUSE WE
THINK WE'VE BEEN LEADING ON IT
AND IN FACT CREE COVE IT- MOST
BERRY CONTAINERS- IF NOT ALL
BERRY CONTAINERS I HAD OVER 20%
RECYCLED CONTENT IN THEM BUT AS
WAS POINTED OUT BY THE AUTHORS
MOST OF THAT RECYCLE CONTENT
CAME FROM. BOTTLES OUR CONCERN
WITH THE BILL IS SET IS WE DON'T
SEE AS OF RIGHT NOW HOW IT
DRESSES THE BACK IN ISSUES OF
ACTUALLY CREATING THE COLLECTION
MECHANISMS. MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TODAY WILL TELL
CONSUMERS NOT TO PUT THESE.
CONTAINERS IN THEIR BLUE BANDS
AND IF SB THREE FORTY THREE
MOVES FORWARD AND THESE
CONTAINERS DO NOT RECEIVE OR
ACHIEVE THE GOALS ESTABLISHING
SB THREE FORTY THREE THAT WERE
SIGNED LAST YEAR. THE ACTUAL
CHASING ARROWS THAT SAYS THAT
THE RECYCLABLE WILL BE TAKEN OFF
OF THESE CONTAINERS. AND SO.
THAT'S ONE ELEMENT THE OTHER
ELEMENT IS YES THEY COULD BE
SORTED TODAY- BY THE WASTE
HAULERS BUT THEY'RE NOT. AND THE
WASTE HAULERS ARE ACTUALLY PAID
WHAT THEY CALL A CO MINGLED
RIGHT. WHICH THEN ALLOWS THEM TO
BRING PLASTIC WATER BOTTLES
THERMAL SHIRT CLAMPETT THURMOND
THERMAL FORM CLAM SHELLS
TOGETHER AND GET PAID FOR THAT.
WE THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
GREATER INCENTIVES SOMEONE
CALLED THEM PENALTIES. ON CO
MINGLE GREAT- WHERE WE'RE
ACTUALLY ENTICING AND WORK
INCENTIVIZE SEEN THOSE TO THOSE
TO ACTUALLY BE SEPARATED AND
THEN MADE INTO THERMAL FORMER
CYCLE CONTENT. AND THEN IT'S
FANTASTIC THAT IF THE BILL WERE
TO SAY- THERMOFORMED THERMAL
FORM WERE NOT CLEAR THAT IT SAYS
THAT YET AND WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO SEE THAT HAPPEN. OUR FINAL
POINT IN CONCERN IS JUST WITH
SOME OF THE LEVELS OF RECYCLING
IN THE GOALS DOES A SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT- WE THINK THAT- THAT IS
PROBABLY UNACHIEVABLE IN THE
SHORT RUN. WE LOOK AT A BOTTLE
BILL THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAS BEEN HUGELY SUCCESSFUL-
AND THE GOVERNOR I JUST ISSUED A
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL LAST WEEK
LOOKING TO ADD A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO THAT PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY HE SPECIFICALLY TO
INCREASE THE RECYCLING RATES. OF
CONTAINERS THAT ALREADY HAVE A
DEPOSIT AN INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE
TO TAKE BACK SO. WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL. ARE THEY
INSURMOUNTABLE NO WE HAD THE
OPEN CONVERSATIONS LAST YEAR
ABOUT HOW WE CAN GET THERE BUT
WE DO THINK THAT THESE ARE SOME
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL STEPS THAT
NEED TO BE PUT INTO THE BACK
INTO THE PROP WITH THE PROCESS.
TO ENSURE IT IF WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A RECYCLED CONTENT ELEMENT
ON THE FRONT END. THAT THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY COLLECTED SEPARATED
BAILED AND PUT BACK INTO THE
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT
CONTENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WITNESS IS TESTIFYING
OVER THE PHONE REPRESENTING THE
ASSOCIATION OF PLASTIC RECYCLERS
OPERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE. LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BRUCE MENYANYI ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF PLASTICS
RECYCLERS- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY- THE
ASSOCIATION PLASTICS RECYCLERS
HAS SUPPORTED MR THING IN THE
PAST WE ORDERED THE MINERAL
CONTENT AND BEVERAGE CONTAINERS-
AND- ADDITIONALLY IN AB FOR.
CORRECT ADDITIONALLY ON AB FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT LAST YEAR- THE
PHYSICIAN PRACTICE RECYCLERS
HELD A SUPPORT AMENDED
APPLICATION ON THAT LEGISLATION
WE DO SUPPORT. THE RECYCLING OF
ALL PLASTIC BUT AFTER MAKES
FINANCING MISTER BROWN POINTED
OUT SOME OF THOSE ISSUES THAT
LIKE THE TO GO INTO A LITTLE
MORE DETAIL- VOLUMES ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT IN THIS SITUATION
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- FORM SO P.
REFORMS OF THEM MOST. RECYCLED
OF ALL THE THERMAL FORMS AND
THEY- ARE APPROXIMATELY LAST.
TWENTY POINT TWO FIVE ONE POINT
75% OF THE TOTAL VOLUME THAT
GOES THROUGH MADERA RECOVERY
FACILITIES ARE BURST. ANNUALLY
AND POLYPROPYLENE POLYSTYRENE
ARE LESS THAN 1% OF THAT ONE
PERCENT. CONSULT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE WE THINK IF THEY'RE
STILL GONNA SIX FEET SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON P. P. THERMAL FORMS.
AND NOT BE DISTRACTED BY BY THE
OTHER TWO RATS AND I HAD
WRITTEN- CHOICES ARE MADE. ON
THE MATERIAL MATERIAL
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE THREATEN
SAFE FOR INSTANCE ALL PROBABLY
HAD FORMAL QUALITIES THAT CAN
KEEP UP WITH THEM SO WE DON'T.
BELIEVE WITH OUR KNOWLEDGE OR
EXPERTISE THAT THERE'S GONNA BE
ANY RESIDENTS WISHING. TO AVOID
THIS TYPE OF REGULATION. BUT IT
IS CHALLENGING AND ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT. THE AT EIGHT CARRY
SUPPOSED THE BILL THIS YEAR IS
IT- WHAT NEXT BROWN TALKED ABOUT
THIS BILL BUT NOTHING TO ADDRESS
THOSE VOLUMES AND COLLECTION AND
SORTATION IN THE CO MINGLE GREAT
LAST YEAR AB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
DID SPEAK AND DID TRY TO ACHIEVE
SOME TYPE OF COMPROMISE OR
RESOLUTION TO THE COMMINGLED
RATE BUT WHAT HAPPENS REALLY IN
IN A MATERIAL RECOVERY FACILITY
IS AMER POPPER RIDER I CAN HAVE
A VERY CLEAN BAIL OF P. E. T.
BOTTLES WHICH WE WANT TO BECOME
BOTTLES. AND THE COMMINGLED RATE
THEY MAY GET UNDERPAID FOR THAT
BAIL THEY HAVE SUCH A CLEAN.
FAIL AND IF THEY- CALL ME AND
PUT THERMAL FOR SPEAKING. NOT
BAIL THEY COULD POTENTIALLY ARE
MOST LIKELY YOU'RE GOING TO GET
OVER COMPENSATED FOR THAT
PARTICULAR BAILE SORT OF A PER
PERSON SENATE. AND HOW THE
SYSTEM WORKS TODAY. IT IS BROWN
SAID I DON'T THINK THERE'S-
THERE ARE HURDLES THAT CANNOT BE
OVERCOME I THINK THEY CAN'T BE
OVERCOME BUT UNLESS YOU ADDRESS
ELECTION SORTATION. AND THE
INCENTIVES THAT ARE PAID TO GET
THAT COLLECTION. THEN WITHOUT
THAT BEING RESOLVED IT JUST
BECOMES THE TAX FOR A FEE ON
MANUFACTURERS WITHOUT REALLY
GETTING ANY CALIFORNIA FEEDSTOCK
BACK INTO THE SYSTEM. SO WE
WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON IT WE THINK IT CAN BE DONE WE
SUPPORT MINIMUM CONTENT THE
TICKET PRICE MARKET. BUT THE
BILL IF IT'S CURRENTLY CRAFTED-
UNFORTUNATE WE CAN'T SUPPORT. IN
FACT WE HAVE TO OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- NEXT WE'LL MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
STARTING IN THE HEARING ROOM.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JENNIFER
HEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I'M NEXT
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THE
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. AND AT
THIS TIME WE DO HAVE IT IN OUR
QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH NUMBER.
FIFTY FIVE. YES- MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE POETRY
ON BEHALF OF OUR PLANET EARTH-
WORK IN PROGRESS PLEASE SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NUMBER. ONE TWENTY.
GOOD EVENING CAL MEMBERS PUT IT
OFF ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA STOP
WASTE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NUMBER. EIGHTY THREE. GAIL BILL
HANNA WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NUMBER.
THIRTY SIX. WELL AND WHILE HE
WAS HERE THE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU CARE
MEMBERS MORE AT YOU ARE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE
FOR PACKAGING AND THE
ENVIRONMENT WHAT THE OPPOSE-
ADDITION THANK YOU. THE. ONE
TWENTY FOUR. ONE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
DENNIS ALBION YUP YUP THE
PLASTIC RECYCLING CORPORATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE SHARE THE CONCERNS
OF THE TWO OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE
THIRTEEN. I COULD HAVE MADE
SYMPATHETIC WITH AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL- WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION CERTAINLY
SUPPORT ESTABLISHMENT OF
RECYCLED CONTENT REQUIREMENTS
FOR THE CONTAINERS BUT FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY MR BROWN AND-
MR MADANI. IT BOTH ABOUT THE
BENEFITS WORKING WITH THE UP
UPON IT THEN THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORS THANK YOU. FOR ONE
TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THAT THAT MIGHT
ALIGNED ON BEHALF OF GERRY- THE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM BUT WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT A COMPROMISE CAN BE FOUND.
FOR ONE TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AT THE CARROLL
PATTERSON WITH THE SERVICE
PACKAGING INSTITUTE AND WE ARE
CLOSED AB. TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR.
I AM SURE THE TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. C. NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. OF YEAH I'LL JUST. MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS LOOK I REPRESENT AG
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF-
DIFFERENT INDUSTRY GROUPS
INCLUDING DRISCOLL THAT ARE
WORKING VERY HARD TO MAKE THIS
WORK AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS
A TOTAL BALANCING ACT- WE MAY
NEED TO MAKE SURE THERE'S
SUFFICIENT SUPPLY OF THERMAL
FORM SO IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ENCOURAGE-
COLLECTION IN THE RECYCLING BILL
OF. CYCLING BEEN OF- THERMA
FORMS AND WE'RE WORKING ON THAT
LANGUAGE OF. WE ALSO REALIZE
THAT THERE MIGHT BE UNFORESEEN
CIRCUMSTANCES REASONS THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY AND-
WE'RE WORKING TO REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES OF
SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAPPENS AND
YOU ALSO BUT- THERE ARE ISSUES
WITH THE COMMINGLED RATES SELL
WERE REMOVING DISINCENTIVES FOR
THE VERSA COMMINGLED THERMA
FORMS WITH BOTTLES AND- WORKING
TO INCENTIVIZE IT'S THE FIRST TO
SORT THEM SEPARATELY. YOU KNOW
WE KEPT REFERRING TO THE
BEVERAGE BILL AND OF MR TANG AND
I WORKED ON THAT I THINK IT WAS
TWO YEARS AGO THAT WAS A BILL
THAT IT IT TOOK THREE OR FOUR
YEARS TO PASS AND IT WAS AGAIN A
BALANCING ACT AND SOME OF THE
MEMBERS WERE COMPLETELY OPPOSED
TO THE ENTIRE TIME BUT IF YOU'RE
WATCHING TV RIGHT NOW- THEY ARE
THE THREE BEVERAGE COMPANIES ARE
BRAGGING THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
MEET 50% MINIMUM RECYCLED
CONTENT AND THAT IS THE HIGHEST
STANDARD IN THE WORLD. AND THEY
ARE SAYING THAT THEY CAN DO IT
SO WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT BILL
IT TOOK A LOT OF HARD WORK AND
IT TOOK A BIG BALANCING ACT AND
WE EXPECT TO DO EXACTLY THIS WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
POSSIBLE TO DO. IT JUST TO
ADDRESS THE QUICKLY IF I LISTEN
TO THE OPPOSITION I WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BECAUSE OF
EVERYTHING THAT'S PRETTY IN THE
BILL. SO YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE COMMINGLED
RATE THAT'S BEEN TAKEN OUT WE
ARE A RATE THAT NOW IT'S
INCENTIVIZING ALL THE MERCH TO
SEPARATE OUT THE PRODUCTS TO
MAKE IT BETTER ARE YOU TO BE
HEARD MISTER BROWN TALK ABOUT
THAT THEY'RE ALMOST THERE
ALREADY AT 20% WELL WE SAY 10%
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND 20% BY
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. SO AGAIN IF
THEY'RE ALREADY THERE I DID THAT
SHOULD BE A PROBLEM IN TERMS OF
WHY WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
RECYCLING ALL THE DIFFERENT
CONTENT. MOST OF THE CONTENT
THAT THEY'VE BEEN USING WAS PER
BEVERAGE BOTTLES NOW ALL THE
BEVERAGE BOTTLE MANY FACTORS.
NEED THAT PRODUCT BACK FOR THE
BEVERAGE BOTTLES SO REALLY
TRYING TO CREATE A SO. ECONOMY
FOR THERMAL FORMS THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES A SO. CALLED
GOING BACK TO- MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS. AGAIN WE HEARD THE
SAME. ISSUES WITH THE WATER
BOTTLE INDUSTRY DIFFERENT
BEVERAGE MANUFACTURERS. AND BOIL
THE HEAD IN HONG FOR TWO YEARS.
AND NOW WHAT WE HEAR FROM MR
MURRAY NOW WE HEAR FROM THE
MANUFACTURERS I MEAN THEY'RE
DOING LIKE. MISTER TALK ABOUT
THEIR DOING ADS BRAGGING ABOUT.
WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT FOR FOUR
YEARS I THINK THIS WILL BE THE
EXACT SAME THING THAT HAPPENS
WITH THE REFORMS I THINK WE ARE
RIGHT. THERE I EVEN LOOKING AT
THE OPPOSITION I REALLY
COULDN'T. DO REALLY HERE MANY
THINGS THAT WE ACTUALLY CAN
DISAGREED ON- SO IN TERMS OF
THIS BILL THE TIMING'S RIGHT
HAND THIS IS THE PERFECT TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
RECYCLED. RECYCLING THIS PLASTIC
CONTENT. WITHOUT REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE DONE
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS ON THE
BILL AND- RESPECTFULLY I STRIVE
VOTE ON AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU I HAPPENED TO
SEE THAT. I WHAT I SAW THE
COMMERCIAL LAST NIGHT- FOR THE
BEVERAGE YEAH IT IT RIGHT BEFORE
HIS HEARING RIGHT I THOUGHT IT
JUST FOR YOU I THOUGHT OF. THEY
THEY TARGETED ME RIGHT I'M JUST
WATCHING TV LOOK PEPSI DR YEAH
THE BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION ALONG
WITH THOSE- WERE BRAGGING ABOUT.
RECYCLING AND REUSING MATERIALS
SO- PERFECT TIMING- I AGREE THAT
THIS IS THE RIGHT TIME TO DO
THIS NOW WITH THE REFORMS AND
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT. YOUR BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR. A SECOND OKAY MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY%
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL JERRY BUSS
HI RIVAS I FLOOR THE- FLOOR NO
FRIEDMAN. GARCIA GARCIA AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I SEYARTO SERTANEJO
STONE. STONE I WOULD WOOD I. K.
THAT THE OIL HAS SIX BOATS WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO
BILLS FLAT- WILL START WITH MR
MULLIN. THAT ITEM ELEVEN. AB.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO. WE WILL
ZACKS. YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SATURDAY THAT THANK YOU YES
HOSTER FLORA MISTER MATHIS BE OF
A MOTION AND A SECOND PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
PRESENTING AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
TWO WHAT I THINK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE BILL
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THAT
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. CLIMATE
CHANGE IS DRIVING CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES HISTORIC DROUGHT
EXTREME HEAT SEA LEVEL RISE IN
FORCES UP THREATS ON HUMAN LIVES
AND PLANT AND ANIMAL SPECIES
ALIKE OUR ECOSYSTEMS ARE VITAL
TO OUR ABILITY TO WITHSTAND
RECOVER FROM EXTREME CLIMATE
EVENTS. ADD TO THIS END THE
STATUS ADOPTED A VICIOUS
CONSERVATION GOALS SUCH AS THE
THIRTY BY THIRTY INITIATIVE AS
PART OF OUR CLIMATE RESILIENCE
STRATEGY TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE.
ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION PROJECTS
HOWEVER REQUIRE PERMITS JUST AS
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS TO. THE
CURRENT REGULATORY PROCESSES FOR
RESTORATION PROJECTS ARE TOO
SLOW AND COSTLY A TO EFFECTIVELY
RESPOND TO ONGOING CLIMATE
IMPACTS IN SOME INSTANCES UP TO
A THIRD OF PUBLIC FUNDING FOR
THESE RESTORATION PROJECTS CAN
GO TO PLANNING AND PERMITTING.
IT COULD TAKE YEARS OR DECADES
TO COMPLETE THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THE ISSUE BY REQUIRING
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY TO COORDINATE
THEIR STREAMLINING EFFORTS. AND
PROVIDE TIME SAVING RESOURCES
FOR PERMIT APPLICANTS SO
SPECIFICALLY. THE BILL REQUIRES
DEPARTMENTS TO RESOLVE
CONFLICTING A REDUNDANT PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS- TO DEVELOP A
SINGLE ONLINE SUBMISSION
PLATFORM FOR APPLICANTS AND THEN
FINALLY PROVIDE CONSULTATIONS TO
APPLICANTS SO THEY CAN COMPLETE
THEIR PERMITS MORE. EFFICIENTLY
AND WITH THAT I ASKED FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES
REGISTERED IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND- OPEN IT UP TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WILL START IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE OPERATOR
Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
AB. TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO. AND
FOR THOSE WHO SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
. IN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THIS TIME WE DO HAVE
THREE IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL START
WITH LINE ONE SIXTEEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS MARK SPENCER
MAKER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE STEWARDSHIP NETWORK
AND WHEN THAT ONE SPOT OF NOT
HAVING POSITION A TWEENER HE
WELL I'M JUST WANT TO APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH
THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE AND WITH
YOUR STAFF. AND REALLY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THROUGHOUT THE
CUTTING GREEN TAPE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS ARE EXPLICIT CONTENT
WHICH ACCELERATE ECOLOGICAL
RESTORATION WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE
THE AMENDMENT MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION LOOK FOR THE FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS TO HOPEFULLY FIND
A WAY TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE NINETY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
MARKET OFFICE ON BEHALF OF SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT- WE
ARE SUPPORT AND AMEND POSITION
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU. NUMBER. ONE FOURTEEN.
ABIGAIL MILE ON BEHALF OF THE
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION SUPPORT. THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN OUR QUEUE.
THANK YOU. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MISTER WOULD. YES SERVICE ONCE
WAS A THANK YOU FOR THIS I THINK
THAT THIS KIND OF A CONCEPT IS
LONG OVERDUE- WE OFTEN HEAR OF-
CHALLENGES WITH- HAVING TO GO
THROUGH MULTIPLE AGENCIES AND
RAY TAKING A BITE AT THE APPLE
BUT THEN THE APPLE LOOKS
DIFFERENT AND HE HAD TO GO BACK
TO SQUARE ONE- I'VE I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN A PROPONENT OF THAT CONCEPT
OF. LOVE I DO LOVE THE UNIFIED
ONLINE- PERMIT APPLICATION
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S A HUGE
STEP TOWARDS WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IS A ONE STOP SHOP NOT
ONLY GET THE APPLICATION TO GET
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM YOU TAKE
YOUR A BITE AT THE APPLE AND YOU
LET PEOPLE. GO AND GET IT DONE
AND SO- I KNOW THERE'S PROBABLY
HEAD WINDS TO PUSH AGAINST THIS
ONE- BUT I REALLY LIKE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND I'D LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL
ITSELF. THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECT LAST
FOREVER THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL JERRY THIS HI
RIVAS AYE FLORA. FLORA I
FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA AYE
MATHIS- MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MURATSUCHI DOT COM MERITAGE III
SEYARTO NUMBER TERATOMA BOATING
STONE BY STONE I WOULD. WOOD HI. THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR MEMBERS
THAT ARE ABSENT THE MANAGER
THANK YOU THINK ABOUT FIRST OUR
LAST BILL FOR TODAY. ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY DOCTOR CORK. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- FIRST OF ALL
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOUR TERRIFIC
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS AND I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS SO I'M
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS. I AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD
BAN THE SALE AND DISTRIBUTION OF
COSMETICS DETERGENTS CERTAIN
CLEANING PRODUCTS THAT CONTAIN
INTENTIONALLY ADDED
MICROPLASTICS. AS YOU NO
MICROPLASTICS ARE EXTREMELY
PERSISTENT PERVASIVE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT HI MICHAEL PASS
EXPERT FOUNDED AIR WATER AND
SOIL AROUND THE WORLD INCLUDING
SAN FRANCISCO BAY. STUDY SHOWED
THAT MICROPLASTICS ARE HARMFUL
TO MARINE LIFE AND OTHERS HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THE IMPACT. TO OTHER WILDLIFE AND YOU
HEALTH. EXPERTS OF RECORD YOU
SEE A PREVENTIVE CAN OF TO A-
MICHAEL. POLLUTION THE REASON
YOU WANT A LOT AT CAN. IS THAT
THE CAN HAPPEN QUICK- IF WE TRY
TO CONTROL IT BY. OTHER MEANS.
WHAT'S THE POINT THE MAIN POINT
IS TO GET RID OF THEM TO BEGIN
WITH. BOB THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO CURB MY TO
PLASTIC POLLUTION CLUED IN AB
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM WHICH
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BLOOM LEGISLATION BANNED THE
SALE OF RINSE OFF. PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS THAT CONTAIN MICROBEADS
WHICH ARE MICROPLASTICS
INTERVIEWS DESCRIBING AGENTS.
EVER MICROPLASTICS ARE STILL
WIDELY USED IN MANY CONSUMER.
PRODUCTS INCLUDING COSMETICS
DETERGENTS AND CLEANING
PRODUCTS. WHICH UNTIL I TOOK UP
THIS BILL I WASN'T AWARE OF-
CONTINUED NONESSENTIAL USE OF
MICROPLASTICS IN THESE PRODUCTS
ALLOW MICROPLASTICS TO BE
FLUSHED DOWN THE DRAIN. THEY
LIKELY END UP IN SEWAGE
TREATMENT PLANTS IN THE
BIOSOLIDS AND THEN THEY CAN WHEN
THE BIOSOLIDS TO SPREAD OVER
FARMLAND OR OTHER LOCATIONS. ARE
THEY CAN BE RELEASED TO THE SOIL
INCLUDING FARMLAND AND END UP
AND PEOPLE. THE EUROPEAN UNION
IS PROPOSED REGULATIONS TO
PROHIBIT THE USE OF
MICROPRODUCTS IN THESE PRODUCTS
. MY INTENTION WITH THIS BILL IS
TO BE IN COMPLETE ACCORD WITH
THE EUROPEAN UNION STANDARDS. WE
STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND
EVERYTHING THEY'RE DOING YET SO
BEFORE WE- FOR WE DO THAT WE
WANT TO GO THROUGH IT BUT TO ME
FOR THIS APPROACH TO BE.
APPROPRIATE AND DOABLE WE REALLY
WANT TO BE AS CLOSE AS WE CAN
IDEALLY THE SAME AS THE EUROPEAN
UNION. SO THAT THERE IS ALREADY
SOMETHING THAT THE- BECAUSE
MEDIC COMPANIES CAN DO THE FRANK
WHICH COMPANIES COULD DO THAT IS
COMPATIBLE- FOR WHICH THERE IS A
MARKET AND THEN WE CAN ENCOURAGE
THAT SAME- THAT SAME PROCESS TO
BE BROUGHT TO CALIFORNIA. AND
HOPEFULLY TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY. UP WITH ME TODAY IS
PROFESSOR CHELSEA. ROCHMAN FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WE HAVE OUR FIRST
WITNESS TESTIFYING OVER THE
PHONE CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE. THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK YES. PERFECT GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR REVISED PLAN AND BY LARA
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM DOCTOR CHELSEA
ROCKMAN AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
WORKING AS A PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO I HAVE
BEEN RESEARCHING MICROPLASTICS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN I
STARTED MY PHD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I ALSO RECENTLY
SERVED AS A COLD LEAD TO
CALIFORNIA WORKING GROUP'S ON
MICROPLASTICS SUPPORTED BY THE
STATE WATER BOARD AND LED BY THE
COURT ONE ON METHODS FOR
QUANTIFYING IN CHARACTERIZING
MICROPLASTICS AND ANOTHER ON
RISK IN ADDITION I WAS ADVISOR
TO THE OPC ON THEIR STATEWIDE
MICROPLASTICS STRATEGY. THERE IS
NO SCIENTIFIC DOUBT THAT
MICROPLASTICS ARE A WIDESPREAD
CONTAMINANT. MICROPLASTICS CYCLE
GLOBALLY AND THE DEATH CYCLE THE
WATER CYCLE FOOD WEBS AND EVEN
HUMAN RECENTLY BEING REPORTED IN
BLOOD. LOCALLY IN COLLABORATION
WITH AT THAT THE AYE WE FOUND
RELATIVELY HIGH CONCENTRATIONS
OF MICROPLASTICS IN SURFACE
WATERS AND SEDIMENTS WITHIN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY WE ALSO FOUND
AND LOCAL FISH AND SHELLFISH.
TODAY THERE IS IRREFUTABLE
EVIDENCE THAT MICROPLASTICS CAN
LEAD TO ADVERSE THE FACT. THE
FACTORS INCLUDE DECREASED
FEEDING DELAYED DEVELOPMENTS
DECREASED REPRODUCTIVE SUCCESS
AND MORTALITY WITHIN OUR
CALIFORNIA WORKING GROUP WE
DEVELOPED A THRESHOLD COOPER
RISK THAT ARE LOWER THAN THE
CONCENTRATIONS WE OBSERVED IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY. ALTHOUGH
DO WE DO NOT FULLY UNDERSTAND
HOW MICROPLASTICS AFFECT HUMAN
HEALTH WE KNOW WE ARE EXPOSED TO
BE A SEAFOOD DRINKING WATER
AMONG OTHER SOURCES. THE GLOBAL
CONTAMINATION AND EVIDENCE FOR
LOCAL RISK EXACT GOVERNMENT
SHOULD REDUCE SOURCES OF
MICROPLASTIC NOW BEFORE THEY
TRANSFORM ECOSYSTEMS ARE
RAPIDLY. FOR MICROPLASTICS
CLEANUP IS NOT FEASIBLE IT IS
CRITICAL THAT POLICIES REDUCE
PLASTIC POLLUTION AT ITS SOURCE.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY SOURCES
OF MICROPLASTICS POLICIES THAT
TARGET ONE AT A TIME ARE
RELEVANT AND EFFECTIVE. FOR
EXAMPLE WE NOW THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS PLASTIC
MICROBEADS AND LAKE ONTARIO
SURFACE WATER THAN WE DID BEFORE
THE MICRO BEAD REGULATION IN
CANADA. COMBINED THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE RELEVANT TO RISK A
CONTAMINATION SUPPORT AB T.
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN HE EXPAND
LEGISLATION AROUND PLASTIC
MICROBEADS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND I'D BE
VERY HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS TODAY OR IN THE FUTURE
. THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION BOTH IN PERSON.
NICOLE CAN YOU HONEST
REPRESENTING THE FRAGRANCE
CREATORS ASSOCIATION. AND MANDY
LEE ON BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL.
GOOD EVENING. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
RIVAS MEMBERS ADVOCATING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MANDY LEE
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL.
HERE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN A
MASSIVE NEW PROPOSAL TO REGULATE
MICRO PLASTICS IN CONSUMER
PRODUCTS WHICH AS DRAFTED WOULD
HAVE THE EFFECT OF BANNING MANY
COSMETIC AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS
TODAY. I AM JOINED TODAY ON THE
LINE WITH DR IAN DAVIES OF PC PC
DR DAVIES HOLDS A BSE AND
BIOLOGY FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
DUNDEE AND UNIVERSE IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM. AND A PHD IN
ENVIRONMENTAL TOXICOLOGY FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF YORK ALSO IN
THE U. K. THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL IS A LEADING
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER SIX HUNDRED
MEMBER COMPANIES IN THE BEAUTY
INDUSTRY SMALL MEDIUM AND LARGE
. LET ME START BY NOTING THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE MICRO
PLASTIC. POLLUTION IS A PROBLEM
THAT WILL REQUIRE CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS. BUT AS DRAFTED AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS
OVERLY BROAD FAILS TO CONSIDER
MANY OF THE RECENTLY DEVELOPED
INNOVATIONS WITHIN THE INDUSTRY
AND SEEKS TO ADDRESS ONLY 1% OF
THE TOTAL PROBLEM THEY'RE
EXTRAORDINARILY HARSH MESSAGE
MEASURES. THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL IN THEIR PROPOSED
STATEWIDE MICRO PLASTICS
STRATEGY IDENTIFIED MAJOR
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE
MICROPLASTICS POLLUTION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND JUST AS
A REMINDER THOSE CATEGORIES WERE
VEHICLE TIRES TEXTILES SINGLE
USE FOOD WHERE PACKAGING
AGRICULTURE FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE. ADDITIONALLY A
STUDY IN THE E. U. ALSO RESEARCH
THE ISSUE OF MICROPLASTICS AND
FOUND THAT THE PRODUCTS TARGETED
IN AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
ONLY CONTRIBUTE TO LESS THAN 1%
AND MORE SPECIFICALLY ZERO POINT
2% OF THE TOTAL MICRO PLASTICS
GLOBALLY. NOT ONLY IS IT
TROUBLING THAT AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN TARGETS ONE OF THE
LOWEST CONTRIBUTORS TO THE
OVERALL MICROPLASTICS PROBLEM.
BUT DEPENDING ON HOW
MICROPLASTICS IS ULTIMATELY
DEFINED THE FACT OF THE BILL
WOULD DECIMATE AN ENTIRE
INDUSTRY BY BANNING MANY OF THE
COSMETICS AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS THAT CONSUMERS FIND
ESSENTIAL TODAY. FOR A LOW AND
IN SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
RETURN ON INVESTMENT. THE REASON
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A DE FACTO
BAN IS BECAUSE THERE ISN'T A ONE
TO ONE SUBSTITUTE FOR MANY OF
THE NON PLASTIC POLYMERS THAT WE
USE TO MAKE OUR PRODUCTS
WATERPROOF LONG LASTING. AMONG
MANY OTHER USES THAT CONSUMERS
FIND USEFUL. AND BECAUSE OF THIS
BANNING ANY OF THESE POLYMERS
WOULD REQUIRE US TO REFORMULATE
THE ENTIRE PRODUCT. AS WELL AS
FIND A SUITABLE SUBSTITUTE WHICH
WILL TAKE SEVERAL DECADES. IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
REMEMBER THAT ALL PLASTICS ARE
POLYMERS BUT NOT ALL POLYMERS
ARE PLASTIC. MANY OF THE
POLYMERS THAT OUR INDUSTRY USES
TODAY ARE LIKE WHEN A WAX FORM
AND ARE NOT PLASTIC PARTICLES
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THE PLASTIC
MARINE LITTER PROBLEM. AND WHILE
WE APPRECIATE THE STATEMENT THAT
MICRO PLASTICS ARE UBIQUITOUS IN
THE WATER AND AIR BECAUSE OUR
INDUSTRY IS A LOW CONTRIBUTED TO
THE PROBLEM WE WOULD POINT TO
THE SOURCES REFERENCED ABOVE. AS
POSSIBLE CONTRIBUTORS TO THE
PROBLEM RATHER THAN US. THE FACT
OF THE MATTER THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THAT THE E. U. HAS
BEEN DEBATING THIS ISSUE OF
MICROPLASTIC REGULATIONS FOR ALL
PRODUCTS SINCE JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN IN
CONJUNCTION. WITH NGOS ACADEMIA
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND INDUSTRY
AND THEY'RE STILL NOT DONE YET.
THIS EFFORT SHOWS HOW COMPLEX
THIS ISSUE IS AND THE TIME
REQUIRED TO GET IT RIGHT. WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO DO WHAT THE E. U.
HAS BEEN UNDERTAKING FOR YEARS
IN THE MATTER OF MONTHS. HOWEVER
THERE ARE CONCEPTS IN THE E. U.
DRAFT THAT WE COULD SUPPORT
ALIGNMENT WITH. AND BECAUSE OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES OPERATE
GLOBALLY IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
ACHIEVE 1100% UNIFORM ALIGNMENT
WITH THE EU MY COLLEAGUE NICOLE
CAN YOU OWNERS WILL WALK THROUGH
SOME OF THE MAJOR POINTS OF BUT
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT ONE IN
PARTICULAR. AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WHAT EXAMPLE LEAVE
ON BECAUSE SHOULD EXEMPT LEAVE
ON COSMETICS WHICH ARE PRODUCTS
THAT ARE NOT INTENDED TO BE
WASHED DOWN THE DRAIN. THINK
ABOUT YOUR MASCARA YOUR LIPSTICK
YOUR NAIL POLISH. THESE ARE
PRODUCTS THAT IN MANY CASES
REQUIRE THE CONSUMER TO REMOVE
WITH EITHER A MAKEUP WIPE. OR
MAKE UP REMOVER AND A COTTON PAD
AND SOLID WASTED. NEVER ENTERING
INTO THE WATERWAYS THESE
PRODUCTS AT THESE PRODUCT
CATEGORIES ALSO REPRESENT A MUCH
SMALLER PORTION OF THE POINT 2%
CONTRIBUTION TO MICROPLASTICS
REFERENCE ABOUT. WE ARE
HEARTENED TO HEAR THE AUTHOR
STATEMENT COMMITTING TO FULL
ALIGNMENT WITH THE E. U. HOWEVER
WITHOUT THE CHANGES- THAT WE
NEED TO THE BILL TO ACHIEVE THAT
FULL ALIGNMENT WE MUST REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU
. GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS
NICOLE CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF
THE FRAGRANCE CREATORS
ASSOCIATION- THE LEAD FRAGRANCE
FREE DISSOCIATION COMPRISING OF
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE ENTIRE
FORGET SUPPLY CHAIN. AS WELL AS
THE HOUSE IN A COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION WHOSE
MEMBERS INCLUDE MANUFACTURERS OF
PRODUCTS IMPACTED THIS BILL
INCLUDING DETERGENTS WAXES AND
POLISHES. WE ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
EXPRESSING THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH INDUSTRY TO A LINE AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN WITH
THE POLICIES IN THE EUROPEAN
UNION. AND I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY IMMEDIATELY. IN
ADDITION ALL SPEAK QUICKLY ABOUT
FRAGRANCE ENCAPSULANTS- IN THE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS THAT WE
ARE SEEKING TO ALIGN WITH THE
REGULATION. FIRST FRAGRANCE
ENCAPSULATION IS ONE OF THE
LEADING SENT DELIVERY
TECHNOLOGIES USED BY THE
FRAGRANCE INDUSTRY AND CONSUMER
PRODUCT COMPANIES FURTHER
FRAGRANCE ENCAPSULATION INTO
TERGITE REPRESENTS ONLY POINT
ZERO ZERO ZERO FOUR THAT'S FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSANDS OF A PERCENT
OF INTENTIONALLY ADDED
MICROPLASTICS. ENCAPSULATION IS
THE MOST RESOURCE EFFICIENT WAY
OF DELIVERING FRAGRANCE REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF PERFUME BY USED BY
ROUGHLY 33% WHILE ALLOWING THE
SENATE TO LAST LONGER. WHEN USED
IN DETERGENT THIS CAN LEAD TO
SOME ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
CONSUMERS WILL WASH TEXTILES
LAST THE LONGER THE SENATE LAST
WHICH LEADS TO REDUCE WATER USE
AND LESS ENERGY CONSUMPTION. AND
ALSO FEWER MICROFIBERS GOING
DOWN THE DRAIN WHICH HAS BEEN
SHOWN TO BE A MUCH LARGER
CONTRIBUTOR OF MICROPLASTICS IN
THE ENVIRONMENT THEN THE
PRODUCTS WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE
TODAY. DUE IN LARGE PART TO THE
SUSTAINABILITY BENEFITS OF ALL
IN CAPS LET'S THE E. U. BUILT
INTO THEIR MICROPLASTICS
REGULATION A BIO DEGRADATION
STANDARD BASED ON
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNISED WE C.
D. AND ISO TESTING STANDARDS SO
TRULY BIODEGRADABLE MATERIALS
ARE NOT BEYOND. THE INDUSTRY
SEES THIS AS THE ONLY VIABLE
PATHWAY AVAILABLE TO INNOVATE
AND CONTINUE TO REALIZE THE
BENEFITS OF ENCAPSULATION. A
BIODEGRADABLE STANDARD TO ALLOW
MORE SUSTAINABLE BIODEGRADABLE
POLYMERS IS AN ABSOLUTE
NECESSITY TO HAVE AN AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN. WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS BEING
TAKEN TO ALIGN THE MICROPLASTICS
DEFINITION OF MORE CLOSELY WITH
THE DEFINITION USED IN THE U.
THERE ARE STILL SOME
DISCREPANCIES AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN MUST INCLUDE A
MINIMUM THRESHOLD TO AVOID
UNNECESSARY ENFORCEMENT AND
LITIGATION. ADDITIONALLY IN
ORGANIC POLYMERS SHOULD BE
EXEMPTED WITHOUT AN EXEMPTION
INGREDIENTS LIKE FUSED SILICA
KAELIN CLAY'S NOT SHELLS AND
CELLULOSE WOULD ALSO BE BANNED.
FOR SO MANY PRODUCTS THERE ARE
NO ALTERNATIVES AND IF
CALIFORNIA GOES BEYOND THE
EUROPEAN UNION ENTIRE SECTORS
SUCH AS FLOOR POLISHERS MARKET
WILL FACE SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE STILL
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
WILL OPEN IT UP TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION STARTING IN THE
HEARING ROOM. K. OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE. I'M OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. DILIGENT IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
DO OF ABOUT THIRTEEN IN OUR
QUEUE. AND WE'LL START WITH LINE
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD EVENING THIS
IS JESSICA GEIGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF THE
IMITATION AGENCIES REPRESENTING
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
PUBLIC WASTEWATER TREATMENT
OPERATORS IN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. ONE AND ONE TWENTY
THREE. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BEST A LAWSUIT ON BEHALF OF
WATER REUSE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
NINETEEN. JENNIFER WILLIAMS WITH
EAST BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT. FIND. ONE
THIRTY. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
MEMBERS PROPOSED KILL FROM OF
STOP WAIT IN SUPPORT. FOR ONE
THIRTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS DEAN TALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A OPPOSE
MCMAHON TO POSITION AT THE TIME
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE OPTIMAL BEFORE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SHANE GUSMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE FRAGRANCE
SCIENCE IN ADVISORY ADVOCACY
COUNCIL WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION FOR MANY OF THE
REASONS STATED BY THE WITNESS
COMMITTEE. FOR ONE TWENTY NINE.
HELLO AND WELCOME TO JERICHO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY. OKAY. FIFTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON ALEXA CHÁVEZ OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE. FOR
ONE THIRTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEFFREY LEE **** ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN CLEANING
INSTITUTE WE ARE OPPOSED TO
BLESSED AMENDED FOR THE REASONS
STATED. THANK YOU. FIFTY NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AARON MEMBERS
THIS IS SCHERING GREEN WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NUMBER. THIRTY THREE. MADAM
CHAIR JOHNSON ALONG HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BASED HEAL THE BAY'S
BALKANIZATION AND ALSO THE
STATEWIDE TEAM SEES LOBBY
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
OH SIX. NUMBER ONE OH SIX PLEASE
MAKE SURE NOT ON MUTE. HELLO YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. OH I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T GET A NUMBER HI THIS IS
KATHY SHAVED HER UP FOR THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU. FIFTY EIGHT. SHARKS
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES IN OPPOSITION.
NINE ONE THIRTEEN. CAN YOU THINK
WITH AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
UP FOR THE REASONS STATED OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. SURE
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS
IN OUR QUEUE. THANK YOU- WILL
BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MISTER WHAT. A PERSONAL THANK
YOU MISTER CORPORATE RING THIS
BEFORE A COUPLE JUST A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR. I AM CURIOUS AS
TO WHY THIS PARTICULAR INDUSTRY
WHICH REPRESENTS A TINY PORTION.
OF MICROPLASTICS WHEN YOU'VE GOT
NINETY NINE PLUS PERCENT OF
OTHER FERTILE GROUND OUT THERE
SO CAN YOU SPELL. THE REASON I
THINK FOR THAT NUMBER HAS TO DO
WITH RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE ON
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY BY THE
ESTUARY INSTITUTE. WHAT THEY
FOUND IS THAT THERE'S ALMOST NO
POLLUTION COMING OUT OF THE
SENATE. THE FROM THE SEWAGE
TREATMENT PLANTS THE BIG PROBLEM
WITH STORM RUNOFF AND WITH STORE
RUNOFF YOU GOT TIRES AND FIBERS.
PERHAPS THE FIBERS YOU'RE COMING
FROM- WASHING MACHINES I'M NOT
SURE. HOWEVER WE DO DO NOT ONLY
FROM THIS- THAT THIS BILL EXCUSE
ME FOR THAT NOT ONLY ARE THE
SOURCES OF PLASTIC BUT THERE'S
ALSO THE PLASTIC COMES OFF FROM
OUR CLOTHES WE WASH THEM. BUT IT
ISN'T COMING OUT OF THE SEWAGE
TREATMENT PLANT SO WHERE IS IT.
I THINK THE ANSWER IS IT'S IN
THE BIO SOLIDS IN THE PLANTS.
BUT IT IS SOMEWHERE IN THE
SYSTEM BUT THAT ISN'T MEASURED
IN TERMS OF WHAT GOES INTO THE
BAY NOW WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE
BIO SOLIDS. IS THERE GOING OUT-
AND THERE'S A- MAJOR- EFFORT NOW
TO GET THEM OUT ON TO FARM LANDS
TO BE USED AS FERTILIZER. THAT
MEANS OF THE PLASTICS THAT ARE
COMING OUT OF OUR WASHING
MACHINES AND- THE GOING DOWN THE
DRAIN IT ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
WE'RE GOING TO END UP ON A FARM
LAND. FOR WHICH THEY WILL GET
INTO STREAMS ETCETERA SO WELL
IT'S NOT A MAJOR SOURCE OF
POLLUTION TO THE BAY. WHICH IS
WHERE THE RESEARCH WAS DONE IT
IS GOING TO BE A MAJOR SOURCE OF
POLLUTION. ANYWHERE WHEN YOU
TAKE THESE BIOSOLIDS AND PUT
THEM ON PLANT. THAT'S FARMLAND
THAT'S FOOD CONTAMINATION THAT'S
HUMAN CONTAMINATION. THAT'S
CONTAMINATION OF WATER IN
STREAMS. DO YOU DOES ANYBODY
KNOW WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
PROBLEM THAT IS I MEAN WHY NOT
BURY THE BIOSOLIDS RATHER THAN
USE THEM FOR FERTILIZER. WELL I
WOULD BE QUITE HAPPY WITH THAT.
AND IF WE DID THAT WE WOULD NEED
THAT BILL BUT THAT'S NOT THE
DIRECTION THE STATE'S GOING IN.
SO YOU KNOW. IF YOU IF YOU THINK
THAT ALL THE BIOSOLIDS SHOULD GO
INTO SANITARY LANDFILLS THEN YOU
WOULD NEED THE BILL. BUT THE
STATE WANTS TO MAKE AN EFFORT TO
USE THOSE BIOSOLIDS ON FARMLAND.
AS LONG AS YOU'RE GOING TO DO
THAT YOU BETTER MAKE SURE IT
DOESN'T HAVE PLASTICS- SO FIRST
I NEVER SAY I'M I'M HAPPY THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT WHAT THE E. U.
IS DOING- YEAH AND I HAVE TO
LOOK. IF I DON'T ALIGN WITH THE
E. U. THEN THERE'S NOT REALLY
CALIFORNIA I DON'T THINK IT'S
ENOUGH OF A MARKET. TO RELEASE
TO STAY THE STRATEGY WE REALLY
HAVE TO ALIGN WITH THE E. U. OR
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT NOW IS WHAT
TO THE E. U. STANDARDS DO AND
WHAT DID THEY NOT DO. AND IF
THERE ARE THINGS THAT THEY DON'T
DO THAT WE CAN LIVE WITH FINE
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WHAT IT
IS THAT WE'RE GETTING INTO. SO
PARTICULARLY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS ARE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A VERY HARD
LOOK AT THE DEFINITION. OF
BIODEGRADABLE MY FEELING IS WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET THERE
BECAUSE IN THE END I THINK THE
END UP IN THE BIOSOLIDS SO IT'S
HARD TO SIT HARD FOR ME TO
BELIEVE THEY WOULDN'T BY THE
GREAT BUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS. STILL WANT TO TAKE A
CLOSE LOOK AT THAT BOB BUT- YOU
KNOW IN THE END I THINK WILL BE
WITH THE E. U. STANDARDS. SO A
CLOSE LOOK AT THAT IN THERE IN
THE PROGRESS OF THIS BILL YEAH
DURING THE PROGRESS OF THIS
BILL. THEN ONE FINAL QUESTION
THANK YOU FOR INDULGING ME AND I
COULD TALK SCIENCE WITH THIS GUY
OKAY. YEAH THE OTHER QUITE THE
OTHER COMEDY CAME UP WAS YOU
KNOW WHAT ABOUT. YOU KNOW
MASCARA OR WHATEVER THEY JUST
WEST OF. IF THE E. U. DOESN'T
REGULATE THEM NEITHER WILL WE
BUT WE DO WANT TO. ALIGN WITH
THE YEARS SO THAT'S- YOU KNOW
WE'LL SEE WHERE THAT GOES. I'LL
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
BUT I WILL BE WATCHING FOR SURE.
AS YOU SHOULD YEAH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. HE NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES- ABOUT ANSWERING
MISTER WHICH QUESTIONS I THINK
GETS ITS THEIR- THESE LIKELY ARE
ENDING UP IN THE BIOSOLIDS WHICH
GOING TO BE DISTRIBUTED ACROSS
THE STATE. AND YOU KNOW IF THERE
WERE NO ALTERNATIVE. THAT WOULD
BE ONE THING BUT THE YEAR WAS
COMING UP WITH REGULATIONS WHICH
IN THE LONG RUN I THINK THIS
BILL WILL COMPLETELY ALIGNED
WITH WE STILL UNDERSTAND THE
SCIENCE BETTER- BUT I THINK THAT
IS THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO GO.
AND THERE'S NO POINT
DISTRIBUTING PLASTIC. CROSSED
THE STATE IF WE CAN FIND OTHER
SUBSTITUTES SUCH AS
BIODEGRADABLE PLASTICS THE COULD
DO THE SAME WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR KIRK WE HAVE A
MOTION. SECOND SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER MURATSUCHI
SECOND BY MISS FRIEDMAN OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL JERRY THIS HI RIVAS I
FLOOR NO FLOOR NO FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA. GARCIA I
MATHIS. MATHIS NO MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MARTUCCI AYE
MATTEUCCI AYE SEYARTO SEROTONIN
SYSTEM. STONE I WOULD. WOOD I.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES. IT'S
OUT THANK YOU. CAN NEXT WILL GO
DOWN I GUESS AND I DON'T FILE
ITEM ORDER- TO GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS TO ADD
ON WE'LL START WITH YOU SEE ITEM
ONE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING AYE
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I SEYARTO
SEYARTO NO. SEVENTY THREE OKAY
THAT SEVENTY THREE DOUBLE AS OUT
- ITEM TO AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
TWO. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
VOTING I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I
SEYARTO SEYARTO NOW HAS NINE THE
BILL HAS NINE VOTES OUT- ITEM
THREE AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I SAY ARE TO
VOTE. C. R. TO NOBODY. YES I
THINK THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
THAT'S OUT ITEM FOR AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY THREE THE MOTION AS
DEPRESSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I SEYARTO NO SEYARTO NO. THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
THAT'S OUT ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETEEN. THE MOTION AS
DEPRESSED AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE CHAIR VOTING
HI FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN HI. SEVEN
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES AT BOTH
SIX SIX VOTES OUT. IDM SIX AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY ONE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN HI. SEVEN
WILL HAVE SEVEN VOTES THAT BILLS
OUT ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING HI FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I'M OUR TEACHING
RECEIVE SHE I. SEVEN THE BILL
HAS SEVEN VOTES THAT'S OUT I
DON'T NINE AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN. MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA
GARCIA I WOULD. WOOD HI. SEVEN
WILL HAVE SEVEN VOTES THAT'S OUT
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS HER
VOTING HI FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I
WOULD WOOD I HAVE. THE BILL HAS
TEN VOTES OUT IDM ELEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIRMAN I
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HI IT HAS NINE BILL HAS
NINE VOTES THAT'S OUT ITEM
TWELVE AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
FOUR MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING AYE
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I SAY ARE TWO NUMBER.
SERIAL NUMBER WOULD BE. THE BILL
HAS NINE VOTES OUT AB. OF THE
ITEM THIRTEEN DO WE NEED WEAK
WICKET OKAY ITEM THIRTEEN THIS
IS ALREADY OUT ITEM FOURTEEN AB
TWENTY TWO NINETEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NO IT HAS FOR VOTE THE
BILL HAS FOUR VOTES THAT BILL
FAILS. I AM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR ROUTINE I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN HI. SEVEN WILL HAVE
SEVEN VOTES THAT'S OUT IN THE
LAST BILL ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
TWO ZERO SEVEN THE MOTION IS
FAST APPROPRIATIONS TURBO
DENYING FRIEDMAN. NO DOUBT BUT
WE WERE OUT OF ORDER THIS IS
MCCARTY AB TWENTY TWO OH SEVEN.
OKAY THAT FRIEDMAN I SEE- TO.
SEE OR TO BUY. HAS THE BILL HAS
TUMBLED STUMBLES OUT OF WE ARE
ADJOURNING THANK YOU SO MUCH.